How I met your mother is the reason that I fell in love with my partner, not the only reason obviously he's amazing but when we first started dating we were long distance and we were looking for something we could do together specifically every night so we started watching how I met your mother cuz we were both huge fans and lo and behold not long after that we discovered there was the how we made your mother podcast so we started listening to the episodes together and then we would watch the episode of television and then at night when we had a chance to finally connect after our long separate days, all the way across the United States from each other.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》是我爱上我伴侣的原因，当然这并不是唯一的理由，他真的很棒，但我们刚开始约会时是异地恋，我们一直在找一件可以每晚一起做的事，于是我们开始看《老爸老妈浪漫史》，因为我们俩都是超级粉丝，结果不言而喻，没过多久我们发现还有个叫《我们是如何促成你父母的》播客，于是我们开始一起听节目，然后看电视剧集，接着在深夜，当我们终于有机会在跨越大半个美国的漫长分别的一天后联系彼此。
We would talk about our favorite parts of the episode and comment on the podcast as well.
我们会聊聊剧集中最喜欢的片段，也会对播客发表评论。
And then we are finally at a year today.
然后今天我们终于走到了一周年。
Today's our anniversary of a year together, and we're looking at closing the distance.
今天是我们的恋爱一周年纪念日，我们正准备结束异地。
And I'm so excited both to have this podcast to continue watching together and also to be able to watch the show in person from our home that we are going to make together.
我非常激动，既能继续一起听这个播客，也能在我们将要共同建立的家里，面对面地观看这部剧。
And I am so in love and so happy.
我坠入爱河，感到无比幸福。
And this show and this podcast are a big part of why our relationship is so strong today because we have such common interests and we're just about to start watching the trilogy again together as well.
这部剧和这个播客是我们的关系今天如此牢固的重要原因，因为我们有那么多共同的兴趣，而且我们马上又要一起重温三部曲了。
So we're going to trill it up.
所以我们要嗨起来了。
So we appreciate you and all that you do to help connect all the the How I Met Your Mother fans worldwide, including two people who fell in love together while watching How I Met Your Mother.
因此，我们感谢你以及你为连接全球所有《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝所做的一切，包括我们这两个因为看《老爸老妈浪漫史》而相爱的人。
Thank you all.
谢谢大家。
I'm alone in New York City when I see.
当我看到时，我独自一人在纽约市。
You just permit me to tell you every city.
你只是允许我把每个城市都告诉你。
Welcome to How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收听《我们是如何促成你父母的》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hey, Craig.
嘿，克雷格。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
Craig, you know how people who kind of make business matches, they get a cut of it?
克雷格，你知道那些撮合生意的人会分一杯羹吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
We make relationship matches like there's no cut of it.
我们促成了恋情，却一点提成都没有。
I mean, maybe it's karma like good karma for us It's the good feeling we have from hearing that message.
我是说，也许这就是因果报应，对我们来说是好报，听到那条信息让我们感觉很好。
God.
天哪。
When did you become so commercialized Josh?
乔什，你什么时候变得这么功利了？
I don't like this side of you But what a great story.
我不喜欢你的这一面，但这是一个多么棒的故事啊。
Thanks for sharing that lovely.
谢谢你分享这个美好的故事。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, that's amazing I mean, that's all we're doing Craig is we're watching these episodes and we're connecting Exactly and we get to bring in other connections.
是的，这太棒了，我是说，克雷格，我们所做的就是观看这些剧集并建立联系，没错，我们还能引入其他的联系。
Do you see where I'm going with this we get Bring it now.
你明白我的意思吗？我们现在就把她请来。
Okay.
好的。
She's right here on the screen.
她就在屏幕上。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
No, we just were talking to her a second ago.
不，我们刚才还在和她说话呢。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
No, she's a producer.
不，她是一位制片人。
Ladies and gentlemen, we're just diving right into it.
女士们先生们，我们直接切入正题吧。
We haven't said a word about even what episode we're talking about.
我们甚至还没提到我们在聊哪一集呢。
We're talking about the episode, how I met everyone else written by an amazing writer and an amazing human being who was on how much mothers three seasons wrote a bunch of great stuff.
我们在聊《我如何认识其他所有人》那一集，它由一位杰出的编剧和优秀的人所写，她在《老爸老妈浪漫史》前三季工作过，写了许多精彩的内容。
We've been trying to get her on here since early season two.
我们从第二季初就一直试图请她来。
Our schedules all finally lined up.
我们的日程终于排到一起了。
The great Gloria Calderon Colin is here with us.
伟大的格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆·凯利和我们在一起。
Gloria in the house.
格洛丽亚来了。
How are you?
你好吗？
I'm so good, guys.
我太好了，伙计们。
This is such a joy to get to sit with you guys and talk about this.
能和你们坐在一起谈论这个真是太开心了。
Man, Gloria, when Craig told me that you only wrote on the first three seasons, I was like, that's wrong.
天哪，格洛丽亚，当克雷格告诉我你只在前三季写过剧本时，我想，这不对劲。
My memory of, is it you were like on seven or eight seasons?
我的记忆是，你好像写了七八季？
GLOW has an outsized impact.
格洛丽亚的影响力是巨大的。
Well, I came back and acted in season five.
嗯，我在第五季回来客串演出了。
You did?
你演了？
Oh, that's right.
哦，对的。
That's right.
没错。
But you also like, I know you and Kobe were really close.
但你也，我知道你和科比非常亲近。
but also like you were at, you were at a lot of the parties, a lot of fundraisers that Craig threw, like you stayed very much in the family.
但你也参加了许多派对，克雷格举办的许多募捐活动，你一直紧密地和大家在一起。
Part of the fam, part of the fam, and went on to create the one day at a time reboot and additional 100 other great things.
家庭成员之一，家庭成员之一，后来还去创作了《一日夫妻百日恩》的重启版以及其他一百个优秀的作品。
You were a very accomplished, amazing writer.
你是一位非常多产、出色的编剧。
We were so lucky to have you on the show.
我们能请你来这个节目真是太幸运了。
And this episode so holds up.
而且这一集经受住了时间的考验。
I love, I really love this episode.
我喜欢，我真的很喜欢这一集。
Well, why would it say, for me, this is like a top tenor, like all time.
嗯，为什么不呢，对我来说，这绝对是历史前十的水准。
like I really think this episode is like all guns firing.
我是说我真的觉得这一集火力全开。
Like it's so good to me.
对我来说它太棒了。
It's so much of the stuff that made the show great in terms of like storytelling and like the blah blah of it all was so fun.
它包含了许多让这部剧伟大的元素，比如讲故事的方式以及“巴拉巴拉”的那些设定，都太有趣了。
I remember when we were talking about that because there was one version where like, oh let's make it like he doesn't remember the color of her dress and the dress changes.
我记得我们在讨论这个的时候，有一个版本是这样的：哦，让我们设计成他不记得她裙子的颜色，而且裙子一直在变。
And we were like, there were a bunch of different things and then somebody landed on, I don't remember who landed on.
我们当时觉得，有很多不同的想法，然后有人想出了——我不记得是谁想出来的了——
Let's make her name blah blah.
让我们把她的名字叫作“巴拉巴拉”。
And that just, it's such a funny one.
这真的太搞笑了。
It's so only the idea that it's a story being told 25 years in the future and you forget people's names.
只有这种设定才说得通：这是一个在25年后讲述的故事，而你会忘记人们的名字。
You don't like, you don't remember.
你不会，你不记得了。
And that was one of my favorite uses of the unreliable narrator, the middle-aged brain narrator, that we are on now that age and we are definitely forgetting people's names.
这也是我对不可靠的叙述者、中年大脑叙述者最喜欢的运用之一，我们现在也到了这个年纪，确实会忘记别人的名字。
25 years ago.
25年前。
Well, it's also, it's so smart because it reminds you this is a story being told.
嗯，这也是，这太聪明了，因为它提醒你这是一个正在被讲述的故事。
Yes.
是的。
And that like, keep a little asterisk by all these details because this is like a fallible memory telling me.
而且所有这些细节都要打个星号，因为这是一个容易犯错的记忆在向我讲述。
This is not a documentary.
这不是一部纪录片。
This is a human fallible human memory.
这是一个普通人容易出错的人类记忆。
You know, my, a friend of mine calls fire channel one, which I think is so funny.
你知道，我的，我一个朋友把这叫做“一号火频道”，我觉得这太搞笑了。
Like it's the first channel that people gather around.
就像人们围坐在一起的第一个频道。
And there's something about this episode.
这一集有某种魔力。
Like just fire on a cave.
就像山洞里的篝火。
Fire on a cave and it's channel one.
山洞里的篝火，这就是一号频道。
I remember like that.
我记得就像那样。
It's the first channel that humans watched.
这是人类观看的第一个频道。
But there's something about booth episodes.
但这些小酒馆剧集有一种魔力。
Like this is a booth episode.
就像这是一集小酒馆剧集。
This is like an actual- This is the fair side.
这就像是一个实际的——这是公平的一面。
And it feels like they're gathered around a campfire telling tales.
感觉就像他们围坐在营火旁讲故事。
The oral tradition.
口头传统。
It really does have that feeling.
确实有那种感觉。
This one, Josh and I talk about like, it's fun going back and analyzing what makes a good how much mother episode.
这一集，乔什和我讨论过，回顾并分析是什么让《老爸老妈浪漫史》成为一集好剧很有趣。
And sometimes what makes a less good how much mother episode.
有时候也是分析是什么让一集剧没那么好。
The idea of filling in the lore, I think Josh coined that phrase.
填充背景设定的想法，我想这个词是乔什创造的。
This is the epitome of the filling in the lore episode.
这就是填充背景设定剧集的缩影。
This is just everyone's origin story, how every single person that is taking the title of the series and now turning it back on all the characters and taking it away from is who's the mother, who's the mother?
这只是每个人的起源故事，每个人都拿走了剧集的标题，现在又把它还给所有角色，不再纠结于“谁是老爸/老妈，谁是老爸/老妈”？
How did these people, what was their origin story on what they made it?
这些人是如何走到这一步的，他们走到这一步的起源故事是什么？
And also like the fun of remembering the Barney Met Ted moments before.
还有，回想巴尼在认识特德之前的那些时刻也很有趣。
Right, and filling in that pilot scene.
没错，还有还原那个试播集的场景。
We would re-shot that pilot scene.
我们重拍了那个试播集的场景。
Yeah.
是的。
And showed you were gonna say in the pilot, like weren't you just talking to me at the urinal or something like this?
并展示了你在试播集里会说的话，比如你刚才不是在小便池旁跟我说话还是怎么的？
Yeah, at the urinal.
对，在小便池旁。
And now with three seasons later, two seasons later we get to show that scene.
而现在三个季度之后，两个季度之后，我们终于有机会展示那一幕了。
That is the most fun thing when you actually get to fill in those like little verbal moments, like the bunk beds from the pilot became a scene in season two.
当你真正能够填补那些微小的言语时刻时，这是最有趣的事情，就像试播集里的双层床在第二季中变成了一个场景一样。
Yeah.
对。
the top-notch moves and it's also fun to see that uh wow Ted uh his hair was longer in uh one of those scenes that they had the pilot one.
顶级的动作，而且看到那种，哦哇，泰德，他的头发在其中一个场景中更长一些，也就是他们拍试播集的那场，这也很有趣。
It's not all again non-documentary.
这并不完全是非纪录片风格的。
Yeah yeah it's he remembered it differently the second time.
对，对，第二次他记忆中的情况不一样了。
Yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah but there there's so much fun I mean this must have been well let's real quick uh uh Alec tell us when this episode aired we just like to oh wow this makes us feel a little every week every time that Glug are ready to be bummed out.
对，对，对，对，确实如此，但真的太有趣了，我是说，这一定……好吧，我们快点，阿历克斯，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的，我们总是喜欢……哦哇，这让我们感觉有点……每周，每当格勒格准备好感到沮丧的时候。
Oh, God.
噢，天哪。
1873, it was March of 1873.
1873年，那是1873年3月。
This episode originally aired on October 22nd of 2007.
这一集最初于2007年10月22日播出。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
Oh, boy.
哦，天哪。
Did they have TVs in them?
他们那时候有电视吗？
Wow.
哇。
I know.
我知道。
The honeymooners was our lead.
《蜜月期》是我们的前导节目。
Wait, Gloria, I often ask Craig to do this, but the title is pretty self-explanatory, but can you just give us like a little summary of this?
等等，格洛丽亚，我经常让克雷格这么做，但标题其实挺一目了然的，不过你能给我们简单总结一下吗？
What's the log line when you say, I guess what is kind of stuff?
当你提到这个的时候，概括句是什么，或者说这大概是讲什么的？
I've had everyone else.
我已经问过其他人了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
And this is the story of how these group of friends all got to meet one another.
这就是这群朋友是如何相遇的故事。
They're first encounter of one another.
他们彼此的第一次相遇。
You get, you get Marshall and Barney, you get Robin and Ted's repeat of that moment told through Bla Bla's eyes.
你会看到马修和巴尼，还有罗宾和泰德通过布拉布拉的视角重现那一刻。
You get, oh my gosh, Ted and Lily, and then we find out it's, it wasn't actually, they actually did meet the second time.
你会看到，哦天哪，泰德和莉莉，然后我们发现，其实并不是那样的，他们实际上是第二次才真正相遇。
Well, you get Marshall and Ted, which is also a callback to, did he already say in an earlier episode I thought you were the Dean?
嗯，你还能看到马修和泰德，这也呼应了——他在之前的某集里是不是已经说过“我以为你是院长”？
I feel like that was a callback.
我觉得那是个呼应。
I feel like that was another time where there was like a throwaway line that we then showed the scene of.
我觉得那是另一个例子，当时有一句随意的台词，然后我们把那个场景给拍出来了。
I think that's right.
我想是的。
Yeah.
对。
No, it's really like you took every character and you drew lines to everyone.
不，真的就像你把每个角色都拿出来，然后把他们和所有人连上线。
Everyone had lines.
每个人都有联系。
We have the actual hot crazy line.
我们有真正的“辣度与疯狂指数曲线”。
It was, there's a lot in this app.
这一集里内容真的很多。
There's a lot in this app.
The sandwiches, the introduction of the sandwiches.
三明治，三明治的引入。
The introduction of the sandwiches.
三明治的引入。
Advent of sandwiches, marijuana, that is, this is the, that became a series, long runner, the people close.
三明治的出现，也就是大麻，这就是那个后来成为系列剧、长期连载、大家熟悉的东西。
Whenever I go speak at a college or play a gig somewhere, I'm always offered sandwiches by the kids.
每当我去大学演讲或去某个地方演出时，孩子们总是会送我三明治。
I say it's one of the most enduring things I hear about over and over and over again is the sandwiches thing.
我说，这是我听到人们一遍又一遍、反反复复提及的最持久的事情之一，就是三明治这个梗。
So it was in this episode, high craze, it's so pure, it's like, okay, it's so pure.
所以就在这一集里，“高潮狂热”，太纯粹了，就像是，好吧，太纯粹了。
It's so pure.
太纯粹了。
It's the storytelling thing, it's like he's telling the kids that and he forgot the name and like we really leaned into the like, the philosophical idea of this entire show that it is a story, it's not, it's an unreliable narrator in every sense of the word.
这就是讲故事的方式，就像他在给孩子们讲这个故事，然后他忘了名字，我们真的很倾向于展示这部剧的整个哲学理念，那就是它是一个故事，不是真的，它在某种意义上是一个不可靠的叙述者。
I really love this one, I think this episode had a real outsized impact, it was really over performing, it has like a whole bunch of things that seem like they were from three or four episodes but it was just this one.
我真的很喜欢这一集，我觉得这一集产生了真正超常的影响，表现真的非常出色，它包含了好多看起来像是来自三四集的内容，但其实全都在这一集里。
Well, the gist is though that Ted has this new girlfriend and we do do a thing, Gloria, we call it old tech, but there's a kind of just, you know, anachronistic things that are like, Oh God, that we're like the online dating.
嗯，不过大意是泰德有了这个新女友，我们确实做了一件事，格洛丽亚，我们称之为旧科技，但其中有一种，你知道的，不合时宜的东西，就像，天哪，比如网上约会。
Yeah.
对。
The online dating, like the shame of meeting someone on the high end month, that feels so old.
网上约会，比如在网恋交友平台上认识某人的羞耻感，感觉太老土了。
That's so old.
太老土了。
That is old tech.
那确实是旧科技。
Yeah.
对。
That is old tech.
那确实是旧科技。
And but I like, I forgot that it was a good motivator because it was like, blah blah doesn't like they're how we met story.
不过我喜欢的是，我忘了那是个很好的催化剂，因为就像是，布拉布拉不喜欢他们的“我们是怎么认识的”这个故事。
It comes out how they really met and she's mortified.
他们是怎么真正认识的真相暴露了，而她感到极其难堪。
And then the group is like, no, no, we all had stupid flawed weird amazing stories.
然后大家就说，不，不，我们都有愚蠢、有瑕疵、古怪又精彩的故事。
And then it kind of motivates why it's not just, they're sitting around for no reason saying all of this.
然后这就成了一个动机，说明他们坐在这里七嘴八舌并不是毫无理由的。
We came up with a little bit of fuel.
我们为它加了一点燃料。
There's like a reason why.
这是有原因的。
And it's sort of based on like the fact that everyone thinks she's a ticking time mom and they have to kind of talk her down.
这有点基于这样一个事实：每个人都觉得她是个定时炸弹，他们得想办法安抚她。
They know she's trouble.
他们知道她是个麻烦。
And they have to make her feel a little better about it all cause she does seem like she might explode at any moment.
他们必须让她对这一切感觉好一点，因为她看起来随时都可能爆发。她在这一集里非常搞笑。
She's very funny in this.
她在这集里非常搞笑。
I will say, Pam and I, remember we talked about this while we were filming.
我得说，帕姆和我，还记得我们拍摄时谈过这个吗。
The five of us together at the booth was a kind of formidable energy, I'd say, like it was a very intense, but I mean, I think, comedically, yes, it was unbelievable.
我们五个人聚在片场，产生了一种相当强大的能量，我是说，那是一种非常强烈的氛围，我的意思是，从喜剧效果来看，是的，简直不可思议。
But it was also like, for a guest star, it could be intimidating, you know, all five of us.
但同时，对于客串演员来说，可能会有点吓人，你知道的，我们全都是五个人。
And definitely, around the booth, all series regulars.
而且绝对都是片场的全职常驻演员。
And Abby Spencer came in and just like, she took over, she took over in a great way.
然后艾比·斯宾塞来了，她就直接——她掌控了全场，用一种很棒的方式掌控了全场。
I mean, that is a compliment.
我是说，这绝对是句赞美。
Yeah, she's formidable in and of herself in this episode.
对，她在这一集里本身就很有气场。
She's very funny.
她非常搞笑。
And she was somebody because the guys were so generous, you and Craig, you and Carter were so generous in letting me be the casting person in the room.
而且她是一个……因为小伙子们都很大方，你和克雷格，你和卡特非常大方地让我当房间里的选角负责人。
And I remember the first time we saw Ivy, I think she had read for something else.
我记得我们第一次见到艾薇的时候，我想她当时是为别的角色试镜。
And we were like, oh, she's too good to like waste on a little Barney girl or a, you know, like, we really wanted to be saved her for this.
然后我们觉得，哦，她太优秀了，不能浪费在一个小小的巴尼女郎或者，你知道的，角色上，我们真的想把她留给这个角色。
We didn't give her that.
我们没有把那个角色给她。
I think she might have gotten very far for Victoria, actually.
我想她当时其实为维多利亚这个角色走得很远。
And we just watched her.
然后我们只是看着她。
And we were like, we've got to wait.
我们就觉得，我们得等等。
She's so beautiful and so funny.
她太漂亮了，也太搞笑了。
And she deserves a star turn and she got it in this, yeah.
她值得一次主角大放异彩的机会，她在这集里做到了，是的。
Carter, I know, also saw, I did like one of those, I think 24-hour play.
卡特，我记得，也看过，我当时参加了那种，我想是24小时戏剧节。
No, it was the young playwrights thing.
不，那是青年剧作家活动。
You know, Carter used to be involved.
你知道的，卡特以前参与过。
Yeah, and Abby was, and I were in the one together with Kat Foster.
对，艾比和我都和卡特·福斯特一起参加了那个。
Did you see that?
你看到了吗？
Yes, yes, I did.
看到了，看到了，我看到了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Because I remember, because that was before I think she was on the episode.
因为我记得，那好像是在她参演这一集之前。
Yeah.
对。
We knew Abby for, yeah, and then years later, we dated, which is, you know, 15 years later, but it was funny.
我们认识艾比很久了，对，然后多年后我们约会了，你知道的，那是15年后，但这很有趣。
I just have to say this that my wife and I, I'm married now, Gloria.
我不得不说，我和我的妻子——我现在结婚了，格洛丽亚。
I have a six month old child, but we, we watched episode eight and episode five back to back just because of the wedding.
我有一个六个月大的孩子，但我们，我们连着看了第八集和第五集，纯粹是因为婚礼。
This is good.
这很有意思。
Are you ready?
准备好了吗？
Are you sitting down?
你坐好了吗？
This is the episode eight was my ex-girlfriend Lindsey Price, episode five, my ex-girlfriend Abby Spencer.
第八集里的是我的前女友林赛·普莱斯，第五集里的是我的前女友艾比·斯宾塞。
I'll be it with a 15 year gap in between them.
虽然她俩之间有15年的时间差。
But we watched them both and Jordana my wife got lover.
但我们把这两集都看了，我的妻子乔达娜非常喜欢。
It was like we're just this is a big day of watching your ex-girlfriend You know not every not every wife I think can hang with that No, what did that what did that feel you tell us paint us a word picture of but I mean you enter her it was strange I think but I think we'd have to get Jordana to come out of retirement.
感觉就像，我们只是……这是个看前女友的大日子，你知道的，不是每个妻子都能应付得了这个的。不，那是什么感觉，你告诉我们，给我们描绘一幅生动的画面，我是说，当你走进她的……这很奇怪，我想，但我觉得我们得让乔达娜复出一下。
I know we need that anyway We're like good.
我知道我们无论如何都需要这个，我们觉得挺好。
You're good.
你们挺过来了。
You guys survived it.
你们俩熬过来了。
I mean, we're still.
我是说，我们还在。
We're still.
我们还在。
Yeah.
对。
So I should say like we, because we recorded those two episodes today, they're not back to back episodes.
所以我得说，因为我们今天录了这两集，它们不是连续的两集。
Again, we had some scheduling stuff.
再说一次，我们有一些档期安排。
We needed to get glow here at a different time.
我们需要格洛在不同的时间来这里。
And I watched both of them last night and I said, Rebecca, this is shaken out in a very strange way because I guarantee you, as we're sitting here on our couch watching these two episodes, Josh is with Jordana watching two episodes where Josh dated the two women And these two are literally the consecutive episodes, but there are only two women I significantly hated that.
我昨晚看了这两集，然后我说，丽贝卡，这事的发展方式真的很奇怪，我向你保证，当我们坐在沙发上看着这两集时，乔斯正和乔丹娜一起看这两集，乔斯和两个女人约了会，而这两集字面意思上是连续的两集，但只有这两个女人是我极其讨厌的。
Right.
对吧。
And we had to watch them in the same night because we talked about those two episodes straight peeling back the curtain of how we make the podcast.
而且我们必须在同一个晚上看完它们，因为我们直接聊了这两集，揭开了我们制作播客的幕后。
Yeah.
对。
I really didn't think of them were excellent.
我真的没觉得她们很棒。
Great ladies.
了不起的女士们。
They were very talented.
她们非常有才华。
Yeah.
对。
Great taste.
品味真好。
Josh.
乔斯。
Yeah.
对。
I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City will be you right back.
我为你写了这首小日子歌，要在纽约唱给你听，马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
Hey, where did, uh, where did the hot crazy scale come from?
嘿，那个……那个“辣妹疯狂量表”是哪来的？
Do you guys remember that?
你们还记得吗？
I don't remember where it came from, you know, it's, I, I, the part of it that I remember what it comes from is there's, there's one detail in there where he calls it the Vicky Mendoza line.
我不记得它出自哪里了，你知道的，我……我记得的部分是，里面有一个细节，他把这叫做“维姬·门多萨线”。
It's this one.
就是这个。
The Mendoza line is a very famous thing in baseball, named after a baseball player, Mariam Mendoza.
门多萨线是棒球界非常有名的一个梗，以棒球运动员马里亚姆·门多萨命名。
Mariam Mendoza.
马里亚姆·门多萨。
And it was the idea of, I think, the 200 batting average.
这是关于……我想是200的击球率的概念。
He was just the epitome of the guy who was right on the side of, is he still a useful player?
他简直是那种徘徊在边缘的人的缩影：他还是个有用的球员吗？
And is he probably good in the field?
他在防守端可能还行吧？
He can kind of hit, and 200 was sort of the Mendoza line.
他勉强能击球，而200差不多就是门多萨线。
I'm like, if you're any lower than that, and maybe you're not a solid infielder, you're in trouble.
我的意思是，如果你比这个还低，而且你也许不是个稳健的内野手，那你就麻烦了。
And so we just took that idea of the Mendoza and made it the freaky Mendoza line.
所以我们只是借用了门多萨这个概念，把它改成了疯狂的门多萨线。
But I was just so happy that Barney dated a Latina.
但我只是太高兴巴尼居然和一个拉丁裔约会了。
I was like fine.
我当时觉得挺好。
Oh my God, it's so true.
哦天哪，真的太对了。
Oh my God.
哦天哪。
We'd show you things.
我们会给你看一些东西。
He's out there somewhere.
他就在那附近的某处。
We never got to her.
我们从未找到她。
We never should have.
我们本来不该这样的。
Oh my God, that is so pretty low.
哦天哪，那真的太低了。
Do you know what really made me laugh was when she, when blah blah thinks that Barney and Robin are together and Robin goes on the nose, with the thing of like, he counted the note, like from the moment she started doing it.
你知道真正让我笑出声的是什么吗？当她——当“啥啥”以为巴尼和罗宾在一起时，罗宾说了一句直戳要害的话，关于那种……他数了那个音，就像从她开始做的那一刻起。
It was different because Kobe was fucking with him and doing it and he's like, I'll just I was actually counting because we shot that I think four times.
情况不同是因为科比在恶心他、也在做那个动作，而他心想，我干脆……其实我一直在数，因为我们拍那个镜头大概拍了四次。
I remember this.
我记得这个。
Yeah.
对。
And every time she would fuck with him in a different way and he counted and it was right every single time.
而且每次她都会用不同的方式恶心他，而他都数了，而且每一次都完全正确。
Like one time it was like 24 and it was really high it was like so high that we couldn't use it.
比如有一次好像是24，数字真的很高，高得我们根本用不了。
It was like 30 years.
大概有30岁吧。
I think.
我想是的。
Yeah.
对。
That's a little bit of like Neil as like comedic machine weird robot she could talk with him and and he would just be, and he was definitely counting.
这有点像尼尔作为喜剧机器的怪异机器人属性，她可以跟他搭话，而他就会一直……而且他绝对是在数数。
He's a, yeah, he had the comedy robot mind coming.
他是个……对，他脑子里有喜剧机器人的思维在运转。
Unbelievable.
简直难以置信。
It was so funny.
太搞笑了。
And then Lily got one in the end, and I think you also did it.
然后莉莉最后也来了一次，我觉得你也做了。
I will say that the come on, Lily.
我得说那个“得了吧，莉莉”。
Come on.
得了吧。
That was funny.
那个太搞笑了。
The three of those.
那三个。
I could, that's also a top 10 favorite 10 moment for me, like comedy moment.
我可以说，那对我也算是一个前十名最喜欢的时刻，喜剧时刻。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Because there was something funny about, he was both doing literally the exact same thing every time, and also like slightly deepening it like every time I try to push her into, I mean, yeah.
因为有些好笑的地方在于，他每次做的事情字面意思上完全一样，同时又像是每次都在稍微加深一点……我试图把她推进去，我是说，对。
The cockiness and it was so good.
那种自大，真的太棒了。
So much of how I met your mother is about memory and nostalgia and the fallibility of memory and how like divergent narratives like this is a really narratives.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》很大一部分是关于记忆、怀旧，以及记忆的不可靠性，以及截然不同的叙事如何——这真的是个叙事。
I mean, I really love the idea that Ted in Ted's mind, he's been carrying around a nuclear bomb piece of information and really has no fucking clue when he's talking about it.
我是说，我真的很喜欢这个概念：泰德在自己的脑海里一直背负着一个核弹级别的重磅信息，而他在谈论这事时却根本他妈的一点概念都没有。
What a good friend.
多么好的朋友啊。
Yes.
对。
I know.
我知道。
It's very juicy, like watching the episode again, I hadn't seen it in years.
这非常带劲，就像重新看这一集一样，我已经好几年没看过它了。
I was like, right.
我就想，没错。
This is a big deal.
这可是个大事。
10 million made up.
一千万编出来的。
Like I forgot for a second, like what the real story was.
就像我有那么一秒钟忘了真实的故事是什么样子的。
It's very juicy.
这真的很带劲。
It's where you definitely lean in as a viewer when you think that's real.
当你以为那是真的时，你会作为观众深深地被吸引进去。
There's a flaw guys because she still went to 110.
有个漏洞，各位，因为她还是去了110。
Right.
对吧。
Well, she still had the conversation with him where he had the cranberry juice cut.
好吧，她还是跟他有过那次对话，当时他喝的是兑了水的蔓越莓汁。
I think they still had that conversation to talk about the ring.
我想他们还是有过那次对话来谈论戒指的事。
Yeah.
对。
Yes.
By the way, Phil Lord, I forgot about that.
顺便说一句，菲尔·罗德，我都把这事忘了。
I'm glad you brought.
很高兴你提起来。
Yes.
对。
That was an amazing thing.
那真是太棒了。
We've.
我们……
I totally forgot writer for look.
我完全忘了编剧是……看。
I know I forgot to because I was like, all right, Lily's going to be making out with a guy.
我知道我也忘了，因为当时我想，好吧，莉莉要和一个家伙亲热了。
And then boom, it's Phil Lord, we should say Phil Lord and Chris Miller, genius writer film makers.
然后砰的一声，居然是菲尔·罗德，我们必须说菲尔·罗德和克里斯·米勒是天才编剧兼电影制作人。
And now Oscar winning Oscar, you know, like, they literally have, they're incredible.
现在还是奥斯卡得主，奥斯卡……你知道的，他们字面意思上就是，他们太不可思议了。
They just in Project Hail Mary, they've done the Lego movies, they've done the Spider-Verse movies that are brilliant.
他们刚刚创作了《火星救援》（编者注：此处台词实际指《Project Hail Mary》），他们做过《乐高大电影》，做过极其出色的《蜘蛛侠：平行宇宙》系列电影。
They were on season one of him with you, Glow and with us.
他们参与了《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季，和你、格洛以及我们合作过。
And they left at the end of season one because they were going to go direct their first feature, Cloudy with Chance Meatballs.
他们在第一季结束时离开了，因为他们要去导演他们的第一部长片《天降美食》。
And two years later, we had the scene to shoot.
两年后，我们有这个镜头要拍。
And Allison was like, I don't know if I just want to have some random person that I don't know as the too much tongue guy in this memory and okay Alec I think we've queued up a nice little piece of audio from Memoryland.
而艾莉森说，我不知道在这个记忆里，我究竟是不是只想让某个我不认识的随随便便的人来演那个“舌吻狂魔”，好吧，亚历克，我想我们已经从记忆大陆备好了一小段精彩的音频。
Hey this is Phil Lord I have been asked to detail the story of my being cast I offer only as too much tongue guy didn't have to audition thank goodness it would have been Disrespectful to my stature as a a juice-paying SAG member I Chris and I were graciously let out of our contract to make cloudy with the chance of meatballs We had a long career killing television shows But with our presence and the the only show That we ever worked on that went more than one season was how I met your mother And so of course we quit in the middle just didn't feel right.
嘿，我是菲尔·罗德，有人让我详细讲讲我是怎么被选角的，我只能说，那个“舌头用得太多的家伙”其实根本不用试镜，谢天谢地，不然就太有损我作为一名按时交会费的 SAG（演员工会）会员的身份了。当时我和克里斯很客场地退出了《天降美食》的合同。我们曾长期致力于扼杀电视剧集，但在我们经手过的所有剧集中，唯一播了超过一季的就只有《老爸老妈浪漫史》。所以我们当然在中途就退出了，感觉不太对劲。
Anyway, we wind up, we're directing our first animated movie thanks to the generosity of Carter and Craig and we got a very strange request from Gloria called it on Kellett who said, hey we want to do this This guy and Allison won't do it unless it's someone that she knows.
总之，多亏了卡特和克莱尔的慷慨，我们最终开始执导我们的第一部动画电影，然后我们接到了格洛丽亚（她管这叫凯利特）的一个非常奇怪的请求，她说，嘿，我们想拍这个，这个家伙还有爱因森不同意，除非是她认识的人。
And would you be down to, and don't take offense that we thought of you for this, but to play a character who kisses her very badly and disgusts her.
你愿意——而且别因为我们找你演这个而生气——去演一个吻技很烂、让她感到恶心的角色吗？
I was like, she really just feels like you're the right person for the part.
我当时就想，她真的觉得你是这个角色的不二人选。
So, you know, I listen, any attention is good attention, so I was happy to be a part of it.
所以，你知道的，听着，任何关注都是好关注，所以我很高兴能参与其中。
I don't remember much else.
别的我记不太清了。
I was unbelievably nervous.
我当时紧张得难以置信。
I remember on take two, I said, to Allison, I'm gonna lick your mouth.
我记得在第二条时，我对艾莉森说，我要舔你的嘴。
And I did, I licked her mouth like I was Marmaduke.
然后我真的照做了，我像马尔马拉（Marmaduke）一样舔了她的嘴。
And I thought it was really funny, but it turned out it was just gross, and the audience, this is an important lesson for those of you out there producing comedy.
我当时觉得这真的很好笑，但结果发现这只是很恶心，而观众们——这对你们这些制作喜剧的人来说是一个重要的教训。
Some things aren't just so repellent that the audience can't enjoy them.
有些事情不仅仅是让人反感到观众无法享受的地步。
No matter how funny the writing might be, no one wanted to look at that.
不管剧本有多搞笑，根本没人想看那个。
So in the final episode, I think I'm on screen for like 12 frames before it cuts to black.
所以在最后一集里，我想我在屏幕上大概出现了 12 帧就切黑屏了。
Now it's quite, they couldn't have left us on doing our make-out sesh while the credits rolled or added a funny button, but it clearly did not merit that.
现在想想挺有意思的，他们本可以在演职员表滚动时让我们继续热吻，或者加个搞笑的小彩蛋，但它显然不配拥有这种待遇。
And it was very clear in the moment as it was happening that this was not going to live.
当时事情发生的时候，很明显这根本播不长。
But anyway, I'm happy to be a part of it.
但无论如何，我很高兴能参与其中。
I love you guys, and I hope this car I'm in is not too noisy.
我爱你们，希望我坐的这辆车噪音不是太大。
Oh, Phil.
哦，菲尔。
Yeah, Phil Lord, I feel it.
是的，菲尔·罗德，我懂的。
It's like, after that moment, I realized I was a director.
就好像，在那一刻之后，我意识到我是一名导演了。
Yes.
是的。
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
As soon as we, that came on the TV rewatching it, I was like, I got to ask Phil for his memory of like, yeah.
一等我们、当电视上重播这个片段时，我就想，我得问问菲尔对当时那件事的记忆。
I feel like he's, I feel like he's missing a bet here.
我觉得他，我觉得他这里有点避重就轻了。
I think Alison was like, Phil wasn't cute.
我觉得艾莉森当时的反应是，菲尔并不丑。
I was like, I think it was much more flattering to Phil.
我就觉得，这其实对菲尔挺恭维的。
Yeah, did she suggest it or did we suggest it?
对啊，是她建议的还是我们建议的？
Cause we thought it'd be fine.
因为我们觉得这挺合适的。
I don't remember either.
我俩都不记得了。
But I feel like whether or not she suggested it, she was like, yeah, Phil, I like Phil.
但我觉得不管是不是她提议的，她的态度都是，好吧，菲尔，我挺喜欢菲尔的。
And he's a cute guy.
而且他是个可爱的家伙。
That's how I make out with him.
这就是我和他亲热的方式。
I think it was much more of a compliment than Phil.
我觉得这与其说是恶心，不如说是对菲尔的恭维。
And he was probably, you know, I remember those early years of cloudy with the chance and meatballs were tough.
而且他可能，你知道的，我记得拍《天降美食》的那些早期日子很艰难。
He was probably like happy to have a couple of them.
他大概很高兴能客串一把。
Oh, yeah, I love being on how I met your mother and we loved having them.
哦，对，我喜欢去《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我们也很喜欢他们来。
It's, I'm so thrilled that they went and did what they did because they built the most brilliant career, but we missed them terribly.
我非常高兴他们后来去做了他们所做的事，因为他们建立起了最辉煌的职业生涯，但我们真的超级想念他们。
They were great, but I remember we, we had our hundredth episode party for how much mother, hundredth episode party, and it was the same week that, or something like that, the cloudy with the chance of meatballs was coming out and Phil and Chris came to the hundred episode and him and party and they were like, congrats on a hundred episodes.
他们太棒了，但我记得我们，我们举办《老爸老妈浪漫史》的一百集庆功宴时，百集庆功宴，正好赶上或者差不多那个星期，《天降美食》要上映了，菲尔和克里斯来了那次百集派对，他和派对上的人说，祝贺你们拍了一百集。
We just finished one movie since we left you.
我们离开你们之后才刚拍完一部电影。
that's how fucking logan takes to make an anime and we're like we did one movie and they have rest you made a hundred episodes um but it's an incredible movie it's an incredible movie it's an incredible movie i love that movie so much my kids watch movie over and over and over oh it's so good.
拍一部动画片居然他妈的要这么长时间，我们当时就想，我们拍了一部电影，而你们拍了一百集，嗯，不过那是一部不可思议的电影，那是一部不可思议的电影，那是一部不可思议的电影，我太喜欢那部电影了，我的孩子们一遍又一遍地看这部电影，哦，太棒了。
they made a music.
他们做了一部音乐剧。
they only make a good they oh yeah exactly they only make amazing things so i had to get Phil's take on that memory because he really had to waltzen two years after leaving the show waltzen and lick elson had against face in front of 50 people and he just fucking did it.
他们只做精品的，哦对，没错，他们只做惊艳的作品，所以我得听听菲尔对那段记忆的看法，因为他真的是在离开剧组两年后大摇大摆地走进来，大摇大摆地在 50 个人面前舔了艾莉森·汉妮根的脸，而他居然他妈的真的做到了。
So great.
太棒了。
You know, it's also like, you know, college names, like, I remember, I mean, so it's, it's too much tongue guy and unreasonably small mouth, open girl, is that what it was?
你知道的，这也像，你知道的，大学里的外号，就像，我记得，所以，就是“舌头用得太多的家伙”和“嘴巴小得离谱、只会张着嘴的女孩”，是这样吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So we had a guy, I don't think anyone ever caught this guy's name at Kenyon College was a very small, and he was just called Birdman because he had a bird on his shoulder all the time.
我们当时有个家伙，我不觉得有人知道这家伙在凯尼恩学院叫什么名字，个子非常小，大家只叫他“鸟人”，因为他的肩膀上随时都停着一只鸟。
He was Birdman.
他就是鸟人。
In the dining hall.
在食堂里。
Good branding.
很好的个人品牌。
Yeah.
对。
really funny.
真的很好笑。
Well, I think there's also, we're always looking, Gloria, for like, you know, what is the shorthand for friendship?
嗯，我觉得还有一点，格洛丽亚，我们一直在寻找，比如说，什么是友谊的缩写？
I think you guys were so good at writing the way.
我觉得你们真的很擅长写出这种方式。
And I think this is why it feels, even though it was, you know, brightly lit and had a sound, a laugh track, how I met your mother feels authentic because of touches like, yeah, that real nickname.
我想这就是为什么，《老爸老妈浪漫史》虽然灯光明亮，还有罐头笑声，但它依然让人觉得真实，正是因为这些细节，比如，没错，那些真正的绰号。
And GLOW, that was very you.
还有“BLOW”，那非常符合你的风格。
That was all you, those names and that idea that you guys were unbelievable, unbelievably gracious.
那完全就是你，那些名字和那个想法，你们真的是难以置信地亲切和宽容。
I mean, the thing that people have to understand, we were so young.
我的意思是，大家必须明白的一点是，我们当时太年轻了。
Like, it was my second Hollywood job.
就像，那是我在好莱坞的第二份工作。
We were, you know, like Craig and I, we're both with our, are still with our people from, from, like.
我们当时，你知道的，就像克雷格和我，我们都和我们的，直到现在还和我们当时的人在一起。
You are Marshall and Lily.
你们就是玛修和莉莉。
You are essentially Marshall and Lily too.
你们本质上也就是玛修和莉莉。
You really are.
你们真的是。
Yeah, we are.
对，我们是的。
We would always talk about like, you know, doing these dating stories and how like we're with this one person forever.
我们总是讨论，你知道的，做这些约会的故事，以及我们是如何和这一个人永远在一起的。
But like something that I really think was so important about the show and I really lament this moment is that it gave a language to what all of us were experiencing in the world at that time as young people, you know?
但我觉得这部剧非常重要的一点，我现在也对此深感惋惜，那就是它为我们当时身处世界各地的所有年轻人所经历的一切提供了一种语言，你知道吗？
And there's not a show right now that does that for 25 years.
现在没有哪部剧能为 25 岁的人做到这一点了。
I agree, it's certainly not on a wide scale.
我同意，当然不是在大范围内。
Yeah, I think you're right.
对，我想你是对的。
There was friends for that time, then how I met your mother came and then like, where's the show right now that's documenting for people who laugh together, for people to like, I read a study like yesterday talking about how kids aren't dancing anymore because they're so terrified to be caught on tape.
那个时代有《老友记》，然后《老爸老妈浪漫史》出现了，然后呢，现在哪里有这样一部剧，在记录那些一起欢笑的人，记录那些——我昨天还读到一项研究，说现在的孩子们都不再跳舞了，因为他们太害怕被拍进视频里了。
And the amount of fun that we got to do and mistakes that we got to make because they're just in our memory.
而我们当时能够拥有的快乐和犯下的错误，仅仅是因为它们留在了我们的记忆中。
We don't have video footage of them and that was so potent about Ted telling these stories, you know?
我们没有它们的视频录像，而这正是泰德讲述这些故事时如此动人的地方，你知道吗？
There's also something I imagine, and Craig and I have talked a little about this, like, you know, it's fun to write a genre piece or something.
我想还有一种情况，克雷格和我讨论过一点，你知道的，写一个流派作品或者别的什么很有趣。
But when you're writing about something that every aspect of your life is usable, like something that happened to you with your family or a bad date or whatever, and all of that can be spun into gold.
但当你写一些你生活中的方方面面都可以利用的东西时，比如发生在你和家人身上的事，或者一次糟糕的约会等等，所有这些都可以被化为黄金。
You know, all your humiliations are.
你知道的，你所有的屈辱都是。
Yeah, it's cool.
对，这很酷。
By the way, the story, I mean, the story about blah, blah, blah, I forgot that some of that was based on that date that Ira had that was terrible.
顺便说一句，那个故事，我是说关于“blah blah blah”的故事，我忘了其中有些部分其实是基于艾拉经历过的那次糟糕的约会。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
I do.
我记得。
Yeah.
对。
I, one of our writers from season one, I had a very, had an experience where he was sort of yelled at by, I don't even, it was, I don't even, it changed it apart.
我，我们第一季的一位编剧，我曾有过一次经历，他当时被某个——我甚至不知道——被某人吼了，我甚至都不记得了，它改变了一部分。
Was it a day, or was it a stage at a party was flirting with somebody?
那是一次约会，还是聚会上的搭讪？
I was flirting at a K-Day.
我在一个 K-Day（校园活动日）上搭讪。
We were K-Day's, R&P K-Day's, K-Day's, K-Day's, so hard, right down the street.
我们在 K-Day，R&P K-Day，K-Day，K-Day，拼命搭讪，就在街对面。
We were there, and there was a girl that somebody was trying to hook him up with, and they were kind of vibing.
我们在那儿，有个女孩是别人想撮合给他的，他们当时有点对上眼了。
And I was sitting, I think I was sitting with Kobe actually and we were kind of watching this unfold and it started so promising and then went real hard.
我当时坐着，我想我当时其实是和科比坐在一起，我们看着事情的发展，一开始很有希望，然后就变得很猛烈。
She really blah, blah, hard.
她真的“blah blah”得很厉害。
She really liked.
她真的喜欢。
Some of what she said is really what we had blah, blah, right?
她说过的一些话确实就是我们后来“blah blah”的，对吧？
She hadn't done it.
她没有那样做。
I was like, I remade some jokes she didn't like and she freaked out and like said some really strange things about it's going to be my year and I'm designing handbags.
我就觉得，我开了一些她不喜欢的玩笑，她就抓狂了，说了一些非常奇怪的话，比如“今年将是属于我的一年，我在设计手袋”。
There was a stream.
当时有一大堆。
On the Superstar, we were discovered that sometimes the most far-fetched sounding things on him, are things we just took verbatim from real life.
在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里，我们发现，有时候剧中听起来最离谱的事情，其实都是我们直接从现实生活中照搬过来的。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew he looked city.
而这位老人，他一定是……爱上了你，知道他看起来很时髦。
And now, commercials.
现在，进入广告时间。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·雷德克（Carl Radke）。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能通过 Bravo 电视台的《夏日山庄》（Summer House）认识我，但在我的播客节目《更多生活》（More Life）中，我将带你走进你最喜欢的真人秀明星们的闲暇时光，开启那些你平时听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的内容，那些展现脆弱的内容，那些令人不自在的内容。
I've sat down with Ciara Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我曾与席亚拉·米勒（Ciara Miller）、多琳达·梅德利（Dorinda Medley）、汤姆·施瓦茨（Tom Schwartz）、林赛·哈伯德（Lindsay Hubbard）等许多人坐在一起畅谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中都会经历恋爱、那些一地鸡毛的事，以及摄像机拍不到的幕后花絮。
New episodes of more life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有全新一集的《More Life》，请在各大播客平台收听或在YouTube上观看。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
Well, I want to pay you a compliment too, because you are very, very good at mining your real life for stuff for him.
嗯，我也想夸夸你，因为你非常非常擅长从现实生活中汲取素材写进剧本里。
And also, thank you for reminding me that you were my greatest ally of the Marshall and Lillie stories, because you and Dave are Marshall and Lillie too.
还有，谢谢你提醒我，你一直是马歇尔和莉莉故事的最强盟友，因为你和戴夫其实也是马歇尔和莉莉。
You've been together since college, right?
你们从大学就在一起了，对吧？
College or right after college?
大学还是刚毕业的时候？
Oh, since 93, yeah.
哦，从93年开始，对。
Right, so it was the same.
对啊，所以是一样的。
It was the same.
是一样的。
Yeah, same.
对，一样。
We may be both met.
我们可能都遇到了。
I want it only.
我只想要这个。
Yeah, I want it only.
对，我只想要这个。
But but but also I will say before I think we'll cut this out if this is bad in season one the idea of the drum roll Please the going to kiss but not quite kissing that was about a young love, but that wasn't Dave, right?
但但但我也想说，如果这集效果不好，我们可能会把它剪掉，在第一季里，那个“鼓声请响”的桥段——也就是那种想接吻又差一点的感觉——那讲的是一段年轻的爱恋，但那不是戴夫，对吧？
It was before Dave where you were just like it was you it was a fleeting moment and you said we can't really do anything We're gonna part ways.
那是遇到戴夫之前的事，你当时就觉得，那只是一段转瞬即逝的时光，你说我们真的什么也做不了，我们要分道扬镳了。
Yeah, that drum roll please.
对，那个“鼓声请响”。
He almost is which is another of Josh's top 10 episodes I think drum roll please the almost kissing that we we were talking about you and praising you when we were talking about that So we should have had you on for that one too.
这几乎可以说是乔什最喜欢的十集之一，我觉得“鼓声请响”那个差一点接吻的情节，我们在谈论时对你赞不绝口，所以当时我们也该请你来聊聊那一集的。
I think we had Ashley Williams on that week.
我想那一周我们请的是阿什莉·威廉姆斯（Ashley Williams）。
So we couldn't have you on there, but.
所以我们没法请你来，不过。
It was great, it was great.
那集太棒了，真的太棒了。
No, that was what I talked to you is what I talked to you.
不，那正是我跟你聊过的。
But yeah, no, yeah, we did the drum roll all night because we were like, we can't, because it was like, you know, new love and you put so much, I don't eat.
不过，对，不，对，我们整晚都在敲鼓，因为我们当时觉得，我们不能这样做，因为这就像是，你知道的，新恋情，你投入了那么多，我不想吃。
That was, yeah, that was like, we were seeing it, Dave and I were seeing other people.
那是，对，那就像是我们当时都在跟其他人约会，我和戴夫都是。
So it was technically out.
所以从技术上讲是允许的。
Okay, so that's why, okay.
好吧，所以原来是这样。
So that's why I'm making an edit it out if it's controversial.
所以如果这很有争议的话，我才要把它剪掉。
No, no.
不，不。
It was technically allowed, but I had a hard time with it because I was like, no, I know I want to marry this guy and I feel bad, but we had this new thing, night in San Francisco, was the same.
从技术上讲是允许的，但我当时很纠结，因为我觉得，不，我很清楚我想嫁给这个家伙，我感觉很不好，但我们当时有那种新鲜感，在旧金山的那晚，也是一样。
I forgot the timeline of who was like, oh yeah, that said makes it even juicier.
我忘了那个时间线是谁说的，哦对，这么说让这事更有八卦味了。
But you were very good about finding those juicy things from real life and putting it in your right.
但你真的很擅长从现实生活中发现这些八卦味十足的事情，并把它放进剧本里，对吧？
Because I think like Ted, I mean, I wanted to create romantic moments too.
因为我觉得就像泰德，我的意思是，我也想创造浪漫的时刻。
I mean, it was such a force.
我的意思是，那真是一股强大的力量。
I mean, it's intense.
我是说，太强烈了。
The fact that he was like, okay, it's such an intense.
事实上他当时觉得，好吧，这太强烈了。
I think people think we made that up.
我觉得大家以为那是我们编的。
It's another thing we made it.
这也是我们编的另一件事。
It's like, no, Glow really had that.
就像是，不，格洛（Glow）真的经历过。
You really had that night with somebody.
你真的跟某人有过那个夜晚。
But he was also like, that's not unlike Ethan Hawken, Julie Delpy being like, let's not exchange numbers.
但他也觉得，这跟伊桑·霍克和朱莉·德尔佩在《日落之前》里那样说“我们别留电话号码了，就约好以后在火车站台见面吧”没什么两样。
Let's just meet back on this train platform at the very end.
我们别留电话号码了，就约好最后在这个火车站台见面吧。
By the way, I did run into him at a wedding years later.
顺便说一句，几年后我在一个婚礼上真的偶遇了他。
No way.
不会吧。
At a wedding, no way.
在婚礼上，不会吧。
I did, I did.
真的，我遇到了。
Well, because I went to visit this friend at UC Davis.
哦，因为我去加州大学戴维斯分校看望一个朋友。
That's how I met him.
我就是那样认识他的。
So I went up, we were running the weekend in San Francisco.
所以我去了那儿，我们在旧金山度过了那个周末。
Yeah, so we were like in each other's periphery.
对，所以我们其实就在彼此的生活边缘。
was deep at this wedding too?
你在这个婚礼上也很深入吗？
What?
什么？
It was complicated.
情况挺复杂的。
It was very, yeah, it was really juicy.
非常……对，真的很八卦。
It was great.
太棒了。
So as a writer, like, nothing's wasted.
所以作为编剧，没有什么会被浪费。
Nothing's on the trail.
没有什么是没用的素材。
It's all great.
全都很棒。
When we talk about crime with some, I don't remember if you guys ever used it, Craig, but I remember one time you and I were actually, I think we'd had a day where they had come for us hard, where all the singles had come for us hard.
当我们谈到……克雷格，我不记得你们有没有用过这个梗，但我记得有一次你和我其实——我觉得那天单身汉们对我们发起猛烈攻击，单身汉们狠狠地抨击了我们。
And we were like, we have more sex per capita than you have.
然后我们说：“我们人均性生活次数比你们多。”
That's in there.
那段被用了。
We just did that.
我们刚刚才拍了那个。
That was like two episodes before this one.
那大概是这一集的前两集。
Because this is episode five.
因为这是第五集。
And that was an episode two or three.
而那是第二集或第三集。
We were like, no, no, we have, if you break it down, I remember, we were like, if you break it down.
我们当时说，不，不，我们有——如果你仔细算算，我记得，我们当时说，如果你仔细算算。
Marshall breaks it down.
马歇尔把它详细算出来了。
Yeah, you're 100% right.
对，你百分之百没说错。
There were probably two episodes ago that Marshall did that exact right.
大概在两集之前，马歇尔就做了完全一样的事。
And he calculated it and he broke it down.
他计算过，还把数据列出来了。
So I forgot.
所以我给忘了。
We didn't really, you broke it down in the room.
我们其实没有……你在编剧室里把它列出来了。
You were like, no, we're making fun of us.
你当时说，不，我们在嘲笑我们自己。
You old, married, sad, pitiful, five, so we're like, no.
你们这些已婚的老年人、可悲的、可怜的家伙，所以我们才说，不。
I would know if you're having good sex.
我怎么会知道你有没有过得满足。
You've only had one penis.
你这辈子只见过一个男人的那啥。
I'm like, take it easy.
我说，别激动嘛。
We have had consistency.
我们一直很稳定。
I think that's so funny that singles came for us.
我觉得单身汉们来攻击我们这事太好笑了。
We know, we know what works.
我们知道，我们知道什么管用。
I think we know what works.
我想我们知道什么管用。
We know what's going to get it done.
我们知道怎么把事情办成。
We know what's going to get you where you want to go.
我们知道怎么把你带到你想去的地方。
Our 1000 hours have been put in.
我们的“一万小时”已经练到了。
We have the, we have the beat.
我们有，我们有那个节奏。
We were the Beatles in Germany.
我们就像在德国驻唱时期的披头士。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
We got our hours and totally did covers and we were under the covers with a second up top, you know, we you were a good ally of like, and I'm actually been making a serious point, even though this is a great bit.
我们积累了时长，完全在唱翻唱，而且我们在被窝里还……你知道的，你是一个很好的盟友，而且我是真的很严肃地说，尽管这算是个不错的包袱。
We you were a good ally in this early seasons of making sure there were Marshall and the least stories with me.
你真的是个好盟友，在早期剧集中确保有关于我和马歇尔、莉莉的故事。
You were really there with me, like we're the old Mary.
你真的和我并肩作战，就像我们是老夫老妻一样。
That's what the fucking show like Ted is huge in the show, but Marshall and Lily that they're the fact that they're the old married couple at 27 is a big genetic piece of the show.
这就是这部剧的核心所在——泰德在剧里很重要，但马歇尔和莉莉，他们27岁就成了老夫老妻，这是这部剧的一个重大基因。
And so I really appreciated that you were part of that voice of me because there weren't many others.
所以我真的很感激你能成为我这一立场的发声者之一，因为当时没几个这样的人。
So that's honestly honestly and but what's funny is that in this episode there's this ostensibly really complicated reveal the Ted and Lily made out that's just completely wrong.
所以说，老实说，老实说，但有趣的是，在这一集里，表面上有一个非常复杂的反转，说泰德和莉莉曾经接过吻，而这完全是错的。
I love that we got to discover what really happened at the end and the tag in the flash forward, it mentions the mother, like there's so much in this episode.
我很高兴我们在结尾弄清了真正发生的事，而且在闪现未来的彩蛋里，还提到了老妈，这一集里包含的东西实在太多了。
This is just a call back though to the earlier point about you guys being the guardians kind of of Marshall and Lily.
不过这只是呼应了之前的一点，关于你们某种程度上是马歇尔和莉莉的守护者。
When we had Greg Malen's on, he was saying, because he was a really big fan of the first season.
当我们请到格雷格·马隆斯（Greg Malins）时，他说过，因为他是第一季的超级粉丝。
Did he come on season two or three?
他是第二季还是第三季来的？
He came in season two, but he was a fan of season one that he joined as an EP with us.
他是在第二季加入的，但他本身就是第一季的粉丝，所以作为执行制片人加入了我们。
But he said, he always hated the sitcom trope of like the long time couple just being And he was like, I really like that you guys were writing a couple that had been together forever that really dug each other.
但他说，他一直讨厌情景喜剧里那种老夫老妻互相嫌弃的套路。他说他非常喜欢我们创作了一对在一起很久、而且真心喜欢彼此的情侣。
Yes.
是的。
And Greg also has that in his life with his lovely wife.
格雷格和他的可爱妻子在生活中也是这样。
He does.
确实如此。
Love who Jenny.
珍妮，真爱。
Yeah, Jenny.
对，珍妮。
Yeah.
对。
Exactly.
没错。
It's nice to see that.
看到这个感觉真好。
It's nice to portray that and put that out in the world.
把这一点展现出来并传递到世界上感觉真好。
The people actually like each other.
大家其实是互相喜欢的。
It also made the show modern because, you know, we had been in rooms where that was not true.
这也让这部剧显得很现代，因为你知道，我们以前待过的编剧室并不是这样的。
That was not true.
并不是这样的。
We're the men.
男人们。
You'll bow and chain.
就像戴着脚镣的囚徒。
Yeah, you don't.
对，你没有。
They did not enjoy their wives.
他们并不喜欢自己的妻子。
They were like, let's stay here because we don't want to go home.
他们总是说：“我们留在这里吧，因为我们不想回家。”
Whatever that was in various scenarios, which we saw.
不管在各种情况下是不是这样，反正我们都见过。
And it was so nice that we genuinely really liked our spouses.
而我们能发自内心地真正喜欢自己的配偶，这真是太美妙了。
Yeah.
对。
And you guys were great also about letting us go home.
而且你们俩在让我们准时下班回家这件事上也做得很好。
I think for those that don't know, sitcom rooms can go very late.
我想对于那些不太了解的人来说，情景喜剧的编剧室可能会开到很晚。
And Carter and Craig were so great about like, no, we need you to come back with stories.
而卡特和克雷格在这方面做得非常好，他们会说：“不，我们需要你们带着故事回来。”
So like go live life.
所以，去体验生活吧。
Yeah.
对。
Come back up.
回来再写。
Absolutely.
完全正确。
Sarah Silverman in her book, The Bedwetter talks about, you can tell if a showrunner has a happy marriage or not by how late they'll be.
萨拉·西尔弗曼在她的书《尿床者》中谈到，你可以通过制片人留大家到多晚，看出他或她的婚姻是否幸福。
What the hours are?
工作时间是怎样的？
No, it can become a real hostage situation in me and on the wedding staff.
不，这在我和剧组里真的会变成一种人质绑架事件。
We're just like, he's not letting us go home.
我们就会想：“他就是不肯让我们回家。”
And how will you live life, right?
不体验生活又怎么能行呢？
How will you bring stories in?
怎么能把故事带进剧里呢？
And how will you go help those crazy moments and those like whatever's happening?
又怎么去捕捉那些疯狂的时刻和发生的各种事情呢？
You need to be living life and mining your own life.
你们需要去体验生活，从自己的生活中汲取素材。
And I think we had a very, and I glow, I imagine as a showrunner, which you've done now for years since how much mother, you become a sure owner on your own right.
而且我认为我们有一个非常……我想象作为一名运作人，你自从《老爸老妈浪漫史》之后的这些年也一直在做，你不知不觉自己也成了一名剧集运作人。
You, I imagine you have a confessional safe room.
我想你也会有一个可以让人敞开心扉的安全空间。
You want writers to feel like this is a very safe space.
你希望编剧们觉得这是一个非常安全的空间。
We can be very honest in here.
我们可以在这里畅所欲言。
You really get to know each other.
你们真正地了解了彼此。
I imagine that's your aesthetic as well.
我想这也是你的美学风格。
Cause that's, you were so, that was your energy in our room.
因为那是……这就是你在我们编剧室里展现出的能量。
Did you feel Gloria that you learned the kind of room you wanted to run was like based on how I met your mother?
格洛丽亚，你觉得你想运营什么样的编剧室，是受《老爸老妈浪漫史》的启发吗？
Yeah.
对。
Definitely.
绝对是的。
Well, the guys were so generous.
嗯，那几个家伙太慷慨了。
They were so generous about letting us, Like, I got to sit in editing with Sue.
他们对我们非常慷慨，比如我有机会和苏一起参与剪辑。
I got to say, you know, like, that was not the case with a lot of these spaces.
我有机会去……你知道的，很多剧组根本不是这样的。
And- So crazy.
而且——太疯狂了。
That's so easy.
太不可思议了。
They had casting, they would send you down to casting.
他们有选角工作，还会派你去看选角。
I would do casting, they let me do casting.
我会参与选角，他们让我做选角。
They let me, like, they really allowed us to produce our episodes.
他们让我……他们真的允许我们去制作自己的剧集。
And it's wild because now, part of what we're also seeing is, you know, my last show, I had producer level writers who had never been on a set.
这太离谱了，因为现在我们看到的情况之一是，你知道的，我的上一部剧里，有些制片人级别的编剧甚至从来没去过片场。
Right?
对吧？
Because it's a stingy thing of we, they want to stop paying the writers once production starts, which is like fucking And Saint Josh and I've talked about that a lot on this podcast of just like, the writers bonding with Josh, you guys becoming friends and, and understand each other's energies makes you a better writer for Josh and Josh, the better actor of your words.
因为这是一种吝啬的做法，他们希望一旦制作开始就停止支付编剧薪水，这简直他妈的——圣乔什和我在这个播客里讨论过很多次，关于编剧与乔什建立联系、你们成为朋友并理解彼此的能量，这能让你为乔什写出更好的剧本，也能让乔什更好地演绎你的台词。
And Melon's insists that the writers have to know the cast, like on a deeply personal level.
梅伦坚持认为编剧必须了解演员，就像达到非常私密的个人层面那样。
No, Hollywood is fucking that up now.
不，好莱坞现在把事情搞得一团糟。
You would bring stuff, you know, I was so close to Kobe, I remember like the literally thing came because she was literally doing that all the time.
你会带一些点子来，你知道的，我和寇碧关系太近了，我记得那个动作完全是因为她当时一直在那样做。
I was trying to remember if that was from real life.
我当时还在想那是不是来自现实生活。
That is stupid.
太蠢了。
Oh, yeah, that's real life.
哦，对，那是现实生活。
Oh, that's real life.
哦，那是现实生活。
And she was aware that we were taking that from real life.
而且她也知道我们是从现实生活中取材的。
I knew I bought her doing that, dude.
我当时就知道她是在学那个动作，老兄。
It does feel true, but oh my god, that's really funny.
感觉真的很真实，但天哪，这也太搞笑了。
Yeah.
对。
But you got to know each other.
但你们必须互相了解。
That's the whole point.
这才是重点所在。
And you feel that in the show.
你在剧里能感受到这一点。
You feel that energy.
你能感受到那种能量。
And you're like one of Kobe's best friends, I would say.
而且可以说你是寇碧最好的朋友之一。
You guys are like dear to your friends.
你们就像非常亲密的朋友。
I was.
我是。
I know.
我知道。
You know what, not yay, because I love it.
你知道吗，不是因为我喜欢才觉得好。
Because it would be her if it didn't be her.
因为如果不是她，那也得是她。
And you, but just understanding each other as a creative team, this idea that that's not happening.
而你们，仅仅作为创作团队去理解彼此，这种事情正在消失的想法……
And I'm so glad that the Writers Guild has tried to fight for that and tried to make the case that that's important.
我很高兴美国编剧工会一直在为此抗争，并试图论证这是多么重要。
And the fact that that's even a battle shows how little the money side of the equation does not understand the creative, the creative alchemy.
甚至这都需要成为一场战役，这说明资本方对创作以及创作的化学反应是多么缺乏理解。
Yeah, we're not with the makers.
对，我们和那些制作人不一样。
I think like shows like this that are like classics.
我觉得像这样堪称经典的剧集。
I think that what was also really interesting is I think that we were all acutely aware at the time that we were making something that would last.
我认为同样有趣的是，我们当时都敏锐地意识到我们正在创造能够流芳百世的东西。
I felt that for sure.
我当时确实有这种感觉。
Were you really?
真的吗？
I felt that with the pilot.
我在看试播集的时候就有这种感觉。
Yeah.
对。
That's really true coming in because you know, when you're when you're staffing guys, what happens is, well, there used to be a staffing season.
刚加入时有这种感觉真的很真实，因为你知道，当你去招募编剧时，会发生什么呢，以前有个“招募季”。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
I know.
我知道。
list, but there used to be a season where you would go, you'd read the script, you'd meet with the showrunner, and then you'd get to sit in a room alone and watch the show before sitting in, so that you could sit like a couple of minutes.
名单，但以前有一个时期，你会去读剧本，和剧集运作人见面，然后你可以一个人坐在房间里看剧，然后再坐进去，这样你就可以坐上几分钟。
I'm like VHS 10.
就像看VHS录像带一样。
Yeah.
对。
How did VHS do?
VHS的效果怎么样？
Absolutely.
确实。
And you get to watch it.
而且你还能看。
And I remember being like, oh my god, they made a romantic comedy in 22 minutes.
我记得当时觉得，天哪，他们在22分钟里拍出了一部浪漫喜剧。
How did they do that?
他们是怎么做到的？
And so it was just so special and such a like specific voice and all the quick cuts.
所以感觉特别奇妙，有一种非常独特的语调，还有那些快速剪辑。
and all that, it was just like, no one had done that thing.
诸如此类的，就好像以前没人做过那种东西。
And if you go to so many of those meetings and you see, you have the privilege of seeing a lot of different pilots, ones that go in, ones that don't, you know.
如果你去过很多那种会议，你有幸看过很多不同的试播集，有的能通过，有的不能，你知道的。
And there was something just so special, and then there was something so special about, you know, you and Carter and how gracious you guys were to all of us, how ever, there was no, I was the lowest level writer in that room.
就是有一种很特别的感觉，然后还有一种很特别的感觉，你知道，你和卡特，你们对我们所有人都那么亲切，不管怎样，没有……我是那个房间里级别最低的编剧。
It was my second job.
那是我第二份工作。
And you guys always made us all feel like we were the same.
但你们总是让我们所有人都觉得我们是一样的。
Like every idea here matters, even our wonderful writers assistants, many of whom got to also staff on the show like it was a it was a really such a special place.
就像这里的每一个创意都很重要，甚至我们的许多优秀编剧助理，他们当中很多人后来也加入了剧组，这真的是一个非常特别的地方。
It was almost like in some ways I think you're in Carter's youth like really served you because one you were you couldn't believe you'd been given this and also like you didn't know enough to be dicks like you didn't you weren't cynical right like and you were really yeah I think I my experience of it was almost a blend of what Gloria is saying, I felt like if they gave us time, we were gonna like write one for the ages, we were gonna make a show that really was a classic in which we ended up doing.
在某种程度上，我觉得卡特和你的年轻真的帮了你们，因为一方面，你们不敢相信自己能得到这个机会，另一方面，你们还不够成熟，不会变成混蛋——你们没有变得愤世嫉俗，对吧？而且你们真的很……是的，我觉得我对此的体验有点像格洛丽亚所说的，我觉得如果他们给我们时间，我们就会写出流传后世的作品，我们会创作出一部真正的经典剧集，而我们最后也确实做到了。
But also at the same time, and I don't know if you remember this as acutely as we did, Gloria, but like we were on a season-to-season maybe basis.
但与此同时，我不知道你是否像我们一样记得那么清楚，格洛丽亚，我们当时差不多是一季一季地在续签。
Oh yeah.
噢，是的。
Something happened, it might have been the end of third season, we got a two-season pickup.
发生了点事，可能是在第三季结束时，我们获得了两季的续订。
It was either the end of fourth season I think it was end of fourth, I think it was end of fourth.
要么是第四季结束时，我觉得是第四季结束，我觉得是第四季结束。
Did Britney Spears save the show?
是布兰妮·斯皮尔斯拯救了这部剧吗？
This is the question.
这就是问题所在。
I mean, it is definitely part of it and we're about to, we're right there.
我的意思是，这绝对是其中一部分，我们马上就要讲到了，就在那儿。
We're getting up.
我们正要说到。
That's a few episodes away.
那是几个集数之后的事。
It was the first time I felt like we got national press, right?
那是第一次让我觉得我们上了国家级媒体的头条，对吧？
Like, yeah, yeah.
就像，对，对。
It changed things.
这改变了一切。
I'm making all the time ever that stun casting worked.
我一直在想客串明星起作用了。
It's so true.
太真实了。
It usually, it's just like, okay, that's a blip.
通常情况下，这就像是，好吧，只是一个小插曲。
And then it goes back down.
然后热度就下去了。
It did seem to elevate the entire enterprise somehow.
但它似乎不知何故提升了整个项目。
It made us seem like you had to keep your eye on the show or something.
它让我们看起来像是一部你必须密切关注的剧，或者别的什么。
It did, it helped a lot.
确实，它帮了大忙。
Well, it helped her and it helped us.
嗯，它帮了她，也帮了我们。
It was mutually beneficial.
这是互利共赢的。
Yeah, that was crazy.
是的，太疯狂了。
You were there, and this was a weird season, just looking ahead a little bit.
你当时在场，而且这是一个奇怪的季节，稍微展望一下未来。
The writer's guilt strike happened.
编剧工会罢工发生了。
Remember, just all of a sudden we just had to stop.
还记得吗，突然之间我们就不得不停下来。
No, I was pregnant.
不，我怀孕了。
I was pregnant.
我怀孕了。
You were right on the day, shot.
你正好就在那天，拍摄时。
I went into labor at how I met your mother and Craig Gerard drove me home.
我在《老爸老妈浪漫史》片场要生了，克雷格·杰拉德开车送我回家的。
I got that glow.
我散发着那种光芒。
Goddamn it towards the end of the scene.
该死的，在这一幕快结束时。
I went into labor.
我要生了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I was, and Craig, you specifically were so nervous.
我当时……克雷格，你当时特别紧张。
You're like, cause I would have fractions, and you're like, get out of here.
你说，因为我会有阵痛，然后你说，快离开这里。
And I'm like, Craig, this could be, it could be 24 hours of this, it's fine.
而我说，克雷格，这可能是……这可能会持续24小时，没事的。
And I was like, you can't sit there and you have to go home.
然后我说，你不能坐在那儿，你得回家。
You have to do it, get out of here.
你必须这么做，快离开这里。
And finally, they were like four minutes apart, and Craig drove you.
最后，阵痛间隔只有四分钟了，克雷格开车送了你。
You're like, I know how to get this show, press a set baby.
你当时说，我知道怎么拍这部剧，生个孩子催催进度。
Oh my God, that's right, you were very pregnant by the end of the night.
天哪，没错，到那天结束时你已经怀孕很明显了。
I was very pregnant, yeah.
我当时怀孕很明显，对。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
So when this episode was being shot and you were on set, you were however many months pregnant, probably a little, and that, you know, cause I think that, the story you just told is the end of season three.
所以当这一集在拍摄，你也在片场时，你已经怀孕好几个月了，可能有一点，而且，你知道的，因为我觉得，你刚才讲的故事是第三季结束的时候。
Yeah, like toward the end of season three.
对，就像第三季快结束的时候。
That was like near the end is when you had the baby, I feel like it was, yeah, I feel like it was very much.
差不多就是在快结束时你生了孩子，我觉得是，是的，我觉得非常接近。
Like we had maybe even finished shooting and yeah, we're right at the end.
就像我们可能甚至已经拍完了，是的，就在最后。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That's right.
没错。
And then he's now going to college.
然后他现在都要上大学了。
Oh my God.
噢，天哪。
Jesus.
天呐。
We're getting too old.
我们老得太快了。
That's amazing.
太惊人了。
You know what I love about this episode also?
你知道我这一集最喜欢什么吗？
I feel like, do you know friends like you know, like you remember the first time you saw a 13 year old friend, a 16 year old friend, like when you met.
我觉得，你知道老友记就像你知道的那样，比如你还记得你第一次看到13岁的老友记，16岁的老友记，就像你们相遇的时候。
And how emblage, if they stay in your life, it becomes, I don't know, like almost like biblical, like the origin story of how you met.
如果他们一直留在你的生活中，这种感觉是多么深刻，我不知道，几乎就像是《圣经》一样，就像你们相遇的起源故事。
And I feel like part of the fondness that these fans have for these characters are, they get to see them in all weather and at different ages, college-led, high school-led, college-wide early.
我觉得这些粉丝对这些角色的喜爱有一部分原因在于，他们能看到这些角色经历各种风雨和不同的年龄，上大学前，上高中时，大学早期。
You're all over the timeline in this episode.
在这一集里，你们的时间线到处都是。
There's a lot of years touched upon, including the future.
这里涉及了很多年，包括未来。
Can we not talk about 2020?
我们能不聊2020年吗？
Can we talk about 2020?
我们能聊聊2020年吗？
We need to talk about 2020.
我们需要聊聊2020年。
So they're in a college reunion, and the Chiron comes as it says 2020, the tag.
所以他们参加大学同学聚会，字幕上赫然写着2020年。
We would just flash forward to 2020, college union, no masks anywhere.
我们直接快进到2020年，大学聚会，到处都没有戴口罩。
They're clearly out of vaccine deniers and COVID deniers.
他们显然是一群疫苗怀疑论者和新冠怀疑论者。
It's funny that Wesleyan of all schools be like, no masks required.
真搞笑，卫斯理大学这种学校竟然会说：不强制要求戴口罩。
No mask required.
不强制要求戴口罩。
Wesleyan getting it very wrong, very un-politically correct.
卫斯理大学这次错得离谱，非常不政治正确。
It was so, I laughed out loud when I came up and said 2020 is like, little did we know.
当时……当字幕出来说2020年时我忍不住大笑，心想：我们当时根本一无所知。
Also, how old we thought we would be.
还有，我们当时以为自己会变成什么样。
Oh my God, right?
天哪，对吧？
Jason's 100 years old.
杰森看起来100岁了。
Allison has like a Betty White wig on or like Allison looks like Geraldine Ferraro.
艾莉森戴着贝蒂·怀特的假发，或者艾莉森看起来像杰拉丁·费拉罗。
That is a deep cut reference right there.
那可真是一个深度的梗。
Not everyone's gonna get that one.
不是每个人都能懂那个梗。
So, Glow, this was obnoxious young us, like 30 years old, like, ha, these guys are gonna be their 40s.
所以，格洛丽亚，这就是当时讨厌的年轻时的我们，大概30岁左右，觉得：哈，这群家伙四十几岁了。
Let's make them look a fucking 100 years old.
让我们把他们化得像他妈的100岁一样。
And Josh may keep on coming up against us because we did this a bunch of times, these flash fours and they look a billion years old.
乔希可能一直想跟我们争论，因为我们这样做过很多次，这些闪现到未来的镜头里他们看起来都有十亿岁了。
And we're now older than they are a lot of that time.
而我们现在比他们当时还要老。
And I'm just like cursing out past us, you and me and all of us, all of us writers like, You thought you were so fucking hilarious, didn't you?
我当时真想大骂过去的我们——你、我还有我们所有人，所有的编剧——你们觉得自己他妈的好笑极了，对吧？
So funny.
太搞笑了。
50-year-olds looked like the cryptkeeper.
50岁的人看起来像个守墓人。
It's, yeah, we really went overboard with that, but it is a very funny tag.
是的，我们在那方面确实有点过火了，但这个标签真的很好笑。
It's 2020, it's college unions are in May.
那是2020年，大学聚会在五月份举行。
I have a quote from my wife, I wrote down.
我记下了一句我妻子的话。
They're 42, they look like they're 65.
他们才 42 岁，看起来像 65 岁。
That's what she says.
她是这么说的。
Jason looks definitely mid-60s.
杰森看起来绝对像六十年代中期（60多岁）。
I don't know what in God's name we were thinking of doing.
我不知道我们当时到底在想什么。
It looks like he's about to retire from the Supreme Court.
他看起来快要从最高法院退休了。
It's also kind of doing a physical thing, like you can't really walk.
而且还有点肢体动作，就好像你根本走不了路一样。
We're so young as we're making that, that we're so obnoxious about, quote, old people who are 42.
我们当时拍那段的时候太年轻了，以至于对那些所谓的 42 岁的老年人表现得那么讨人嫌。
It's really unacceptable.
这真的很过分。
Yeah.
是啊。
You know what is, I've been, this has been pointed out to me over the years, but I love them having sandwiches by the vending machines at the end.
你知道吗，我一直在——这些年来有人向我指出来过，但我特别喜欢他们在最后的自动售货机旁吃三明治。
Yeah, I love that scene.
对，我也喜欢那一幕。
It's really sweet.
真的很温馨。
Also, when Ted starts laughing at the end, where's my wife?
还有，当特德最后笑的时候，我的老婆呢？
Where's my wife?
我的老婆呢？
He's the whole show.
他整场戏的精髓都在这了。
It's the whole show.
这就是整场戏的灵魂。
He sums up the entire show.
他概括了整场戏的精髓。
It's a throwaway stony line.
这只是一句随口说出的关于“三明治”的台词。
Yeah, but it's the whole show in one line.
对，但这一句话就浓缩了整场戏。
It's like the DNA in one little cell of like what's, yeah, like I know.
就像DNA一样，在一个小细胞里包含了那种——对，就像我懂的。
It's like prismatic.
就像三棱镜一样。
Like the whole is contained in the part.
就像整体包含在局部之中。
Yes.
是的。
I love that.
我太喜欢了。
I know me too.
我知道，我也是。
I find it so moving.
我觉得这太感人了。
It's very moving.
非常感人。
And I also remember, sometimes you just, I see these scenes and I remember, oh, that was fun.
而且我也记得，有时候你就是——我看到这些场景，然后我想起，哦，那真是有趣。
Like, I remember sitting on the ground, eating sandwiches with Jason and Allie and just having a blast.
比如，我记得自己坐在地上，和杰森还有艾莉一起吃三明治，玩得太开心了。
Like the kind of like, I can't believe this is my job kind of days.
那种感觉就像是，简直不敢相信这就是我的工作。
Yeah.
对。
It feels that way.
感觉确实如此。
That seems feels that way.
感觉就是那样。
It feels very loose and very fun and very real.
感觉非常放松、非常有趣、非常真实。
Like we're getting this wonderful little glimpse.
就像我们得以窥见这美妙的一小瞥。
They're all still friends in the future.
他们以后都还是朋友。
Ted's wife is definitely there.
特德的妻子绝对也在那里。
We're just she's off camera somewhere.
我们只是——她刚好在镜头拍不到的地方。
It's very exciting.
这太令人兴奋了。
I also felt like we knew the moment sandwiches landed in our laps.
我还觉得，我们一拿到三明治，心里就有数了。
Like we knew we had a bit.
就像我们知道我们有个好笑点。
We had a good bit.
我们有个很棒的梗。
I think that's a carter-based bit.
我觉得这是一个基于卡特（Carter）的梗。
And you knew that it was not going to be the last time you see.
而且你知道这绝不会是最后一次看到。
Yeah, sandwiches was pretty recurring.
对，三明治是个很经常出现的元素。
It's it's a great.
这是一个很棒的——
It's one of the top five things I hear most about is sandwiches.
这是我听到大家谈论最多的前五大话题之一，就是三明治。
And if you meet someone in their 20s, they'll be like, ah, it's we'd smoke, we had some sandwiches and like every time they reference, they that's the go to him, you reference a couple questions or observation.
如果你遇到二十多岁的人，他们会说：“啊，我们会抽叶子，吃点三明治”，每次他们提到时，那就是他们的首选话题，你提到了几个问题或观察。
I really made me laugh when Barney turns to Ted in the bathroom says, I like you Ted.
巴尼在浴室里转过身对特德说“我喜欢你，特德”，这真的让我大笑。
Like for some reason, he just gets it in his head.
不知道为什么，他脑子里突然冒出这个念头。
Like I'm going to I'm going to use my way into this guy's life.
就像“我要——我要想方设法混进这家伙的生活”。
This is the guy.
就是这家伙。
This is a guy.
就是这个人。
Yeah, it's in a way that's like that's the one for Barney.
对，某种程度上，这就是巴尼的“命中注定”。
Yeah, Barney has met his one.
对，巴尼遇到了他的“真命天子”。
We have a running thing on this podcast, Gloria, where I'm pretty sure that how I met your mother had weird prophetic qualities without realizing it.
格洛丽亚，我们这个播客里有一个惯例，我挺确信《老爸老妈浪漫史》在不知不觉中有一种奇怪的预言属性。
Except about COVID.
除了关于新冠疫情。
It missed a very big one, but it got some smaller ones.
它漏掉了非常大的一项，但它命中了一些小一点的。
Okay.
好吧。
In 2007, Robin has a run about subprime mortgages that was before the 2008 crash.
2007年，罗宾有一段关于次级抵押贷款的吐槽，那是在2008年金融危机之前。
Yeah, we discovered that which I thought was pretty extraordinary early also Talking Barney talking about Ted's tiny lady like hands.
对，我们发现了这一点，我觉得这在当时也非常了不起。还有，巴尼谈到特德那像小姑娘一样的手。
I think really prophesies Trump Yes, I mean look a lot about Barney's world.
我觉得真的预言了特朗普。是的，我是说，看看巴尼世界的很多方面。
Yeah There were two these two apps back to back not only had ex-girlfriends of mine, but both had sign language Yes, yes, they both had something which and Alec why don't you pop in Alec Lev who one of his many Alec, Alec is a man of many talents.
对，连续两集里不仅有我的前女友，而且都用到了手语。是的，是的，这两集都有一些——亚历克，你为什么不插话呢？亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev），他拥有众多——亚历克，亚历克是个多才多艺的人。
He's a Renaissance man.
他是个文艺复兴式的人物。
He is a very highly skilled sign language interpreter, has interpreted for Paul McCartney concert, has interpreted for Barack Obama.
他是一位技艺高超的手语翻译，曾为保罗·麦卡特尼的演唱会做过翻译，也曾为巴拉克·奥巴马做过翻译。
Am I lying, Alec?
我在撒谎吗，亚历克？
All in the street, right?
就在大街上，对吧？
You are not lying.
你没有撒谎。
And is the go to when we need a sign language on how much your mother, we would call Alex before Alec even worked on the show, right?
而且每当我们需要在《老爸老妈浪漫史》里用到手语时，他就是我们的首选。甚至在亚历克为这部剧工作之前，我们就会打电话给亚历克，对吧？
This is before you were doing like digital and DVD and new media stuff.
这是在你做数字内容、DVD和新媒体那些工作之前。
This is season three.
这是第三季。
And we called upon you twice, right, and quick succession to do ASL, right?
我们连续找了你两次，对吧，紧接着要你做美国手语（ASL），对吧？
You probably taught Josh.
你可能教过乔什。
And it was all with me, I think I was always the signer.
而且都是跟我合作的，我想我一直是那个打手语的人。
That's right, I had done a couple of the behind the scenes features in season two, Carl had hired me to do that, to do a couple of making of bits, also in season three.
没错，我在第二季时做过一些幕后花絮特辑，卡尔雇我去做那个，做一些幕后制作的短片，第三季也是。
But then yes, I was hired for a couple of dollars to be your sign language consultant on both of those episodes.
不过后来是的，我拿了点工钱，在那两集里担任你们的手语顾问。
The production is okay, your sign production's okay.
你的制作还好，你的手语制作还行。
It got the job done.
把活儿干成了。
Yeah, he got us where we wanted to go.
对，他把我们带到了我们想去的地方。
Ted will get you where you need to go.
特德会把你带到你需要去的地方。
That line, though, from Kobe Ted is very good.
不过，科比·特德的那句台词真的很棒。
I'm sure he will get you where he needs you.
我确信他会把你带到他需要你去的地方。
That makes me laugh so much.
这让我笑得不行。
And that's all we're looking for.
而这正是我们所寻找的。
Where the Shelly Gillespie Zone come from?
雪莉·吉莱斯皮区（Shelly Gillespie Zone）是从哪来的？
Shelly Gillespie was a girl that was mean to me in grade school.
雪莉·吉莱斯皮是我小学时对我很坏的一个女孩。
Oh, my God.
哦，天哪。
You always came up with good names.
你总是能想出好名字。
Oh, I did it.
哦，确实如此。
I got the Alexa, what's my college roommate?
我有过——阿列克谢（Alexa），我大学室友叫什么来着？
And I remember that that was a real name.
我记得那是个真名。
It's a great name.
真是个好名字。
Alexa, he was delighted.
阿列克谢，他很高兴。
I asked her, I did not ask Shelly.
我问的是她，我没问雪莉。
Of course, it's not only, your history is not only useful for plot devices, also for revenge.
当然，不仅如此，你的历史不仅对剧情有用，对复仇也很有用。
Exactly.
没错。
For revenge.
为了复仇。
For sweet, sweet revenge.
为了甜蜜的复仇。
Yeah, take that Shelly Gillespie.
对，接招吧，雪莉·吉莱斯皮。
I like when Ted says I cut it with cranberry juice because it was pretty strong.
我挺喜欢泰德说他在里面兑了蔓越莓汁，因为酒劲太强。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
It's a pinot noir.
那是黑皮诺。
I cut it with green red juice.
我兑了绿红果汁。
I cut it with a glass of wine.
我兑了一杯酒。
It's so delicious.
这太美味了。
It's so good.
太棒了。
It's with his spectacles and the glass of wine.
还有他的眼镜和那杯酒。
There was always the one guy, the glass of wine.
总会有那么一个人，端着一杯酒。
Look at these peasants around me, but he put cranberry juice in it.
看看我周围这些乡巴佬，但他却在里面加了蔓越莓汁。
It's good.
这很好喝。
We really cover a lot of ground in this episode.
我们这集聊的内容可真够广泛的。
A lot of years.
跨越了很多年。
It's a very flashy, forwardy-backy episode.
这一集闪来闪去，时空跳跃得很厉害。
I do remember really loving doing the crying phone called a Karen.
我确实记得当年哭着打那个叫凯伦的电话演得特别开心。
Yes, and quoting Descartes and then saying I sent you an electronic man electronic I went to the campus center and sent you an electronic mail which is what you had to do you had to do yeah because Dave was at Notre Dame when I was a freshman 17 minutes it would take oh my god yeah now I remember walking to get there you had to walk to send an electronic mail I sent you You had to go to the place.
对，还有引用笛卡尔的话，然后说我给你发了个电子人，电子……我去了校园中心，给你发了一封电子信函，这就是你当时必须得做的事，你必须得那样做，对，因为当我是大一新生的时候，戴夫在圣母大学，那得花17分钟，哦天哪，对，现在我记得走过去拿邮件，你得走过去才能发出一封电子信函，我给你发了，你得去那个地方。
College Ted is so is just nonstop home runs.
大学泰德的表现简直是全垒打，停不下来。
College Ted does not think so.
大学泰德可不这么觉得。
You're so good.
你演得太棒了。
It's so, you have, you can see you having fun with that.
太棒了，你能看出你在其中玩得很开心。
Was it a Riva Deertre Fierro where he came on kind of as college Ted?
是那集《里瓦·迪尔特·菲尔罗》里，他以大学泰德的形象出场的吗？
I think that was, because that was their big road trip home.
我想是的，因为那是他们回家的那次漫长公路旅行。
That was, my parents live in Ohio.
那是，我父母住在俄亥俄州。
I live in the moment.
我活在当下。
Yes, that was, that was the big entrance.
对，那是，那是重磅登场。
And I was like, we're going to keep going back to this.
当时我想，我们会一直不断地回顾这个梗。
And he was such a reliable world to go to.
而且他是一个如此靠谱、可以随时回归的世界。
I love when, I think it's, wait, who says, is it Ted or Marshall who says he's gonna use force?
我喜欢……我觉得是，等等，谁说的？是泰德还是马歇尔说他要使用原力？
Cause that sounds wrong.
因为听起来怪怪的。
That sounds right.
听起来挺对的。
It's Broda.
是巴罗达。
I'm gonna use the force to get a girl.
我要用原力来泡妞。
That's what you give in Barney shit.
那就是你给巴尼出的馊主意。
Yes.
没错。
Which is a great speed.
这节奏太棒了。
I love that bit.
我太喜欢那个桥段了。
The lily Marshall and him doing his laundry for the next two weeks.
莉莉、马歇尔还有他，帮他洗接下来两个星期的衣服。
That man is a God.
那家伙简直是个神。
Yeah.
对啊。
It's great seeing Barney lose.
看巴尼吃瘪真是太棒了。
You need to see Barney when we talk about this a lot.
我们经常讨论这个，你得看看巴尼吃瘪的样子。
He needs to get duped.
他得被狠狠耍一次。
Yeah.
没错。
He needs Barney needs no.
巴尼他需要……不。
He needs a regular come up and to balance the scales of justice.
他需要经历一次惨败，来平衡正义的天平。
Oh, yeah, it's a pain.
哦，对，这挺不容易的。
We know where it came from.
我们知道这是从哪来的。
It all as it does with some of the time.
跟往常一样，一切皆有缘由。
He's so sociopathic and evil that you're like, wait a minute.
他那么有反社会倾向又邪恶，以至于你会想，等等。
Well, you wrote another one where we peeled back the layers.
好吧，你们还写了另一集，我们在其中剥茧抽丝。
And season to the showdown episode where we went and Bob Barker's his dad.
第二季的对决那一集，我们去了那里，鲍勃·巴克成了他爸爸。
But not really we that was the beginning of really excavating until like Barney's carrying some real baggage here Like there's a reason he's the way he is and that was that was an important well those guys aren't listen the man is here The man is fear needs to be a you know dismantled and it's those guys were in pain they're in deep in I know exactly and they've all put on their little suits of armor Like Barney has a literal suit of suiteness, but it's like there's a scars underneath there And some of my proudest things about Barney on the series are when we dug into that and Showdown was a great early example.
但其实并非如此，那是真正深入挖掘的开始，就像巴尼身上背负着沉重的包袱一样，他变成现在这样是有原因的，那是一个重要的……好吧，那些家伙可不听这一套，这人是个威胁，这人是个威胁，需要被你知道的……被瓦解，而那些家伙当时很痛苦，他们陷入极深的痛苦中，我完全明白，他们都穿上了各自的小铠甲，就像巴尼有一套字面意义上的西装革履，但这就像是西装下隐藏着伤疤一样，我在这个系列中对巴尼最引以为傲的事情之一，就是我们深入挖掘了这一点，而《对决》就是一个很好的早期例子。
I mean, in season one, also we did the sort of how Barney became Barney episode.
我是说，在第一季里，我们还拍了那集类似“巴尼是如何成为巴尼”的剧集。
Remember that's where the Darth Vader thing, that was kind of the predecessor to Showdown.
还记得达斯·维达那个梗吗，那可以说是《对决》的前身。
And like each season we found new things.
而且每一季我们都会发现新的东西。
And I think that's really important.
我觉得这非常重要。
You guys were always alert to what was fueling that was like pain and abandonment.
你们总是敏锐地察觉到，驱动这一切的其实是痛苦和被抛弃感。
Like, yeah, you were never trying to be like.
就像，是的，你们从来没想过去塑造……
Well, I would say that's another prophetic hymnium thing because look where we are.
好吧，我要说这也是另一个颇具先见之明的“Hemium”时刻，因为看看我们现在所在的位置。
It's like, we're so in that right now.
就像，我们现在完全陷入其中了。
It's ridiculous if we could just take into that.
如果我们能深入探讨一下，那就太荒谬了。
Oh, correct, this is actually a good segue.
哦，没错，这其实是一个很好的过渡。
I was telling, Gloria, I was telling him that in a first season radio tour, I don't know if you remember, we had to do these radio tours.
我刚才在跟格洛里亚说，我在第一季的电台巡回宣传时，我不知道你们记不记得，我们当时必须得做这些电台巡回。
We'd get up early in the morning.
我们得一大早起床。
And they patch you through to like 12 or 15 radio stations around the country to interview you for five minutes about how I made your mother.
然后他们会把你连线到全国大约12到15个广播电台，让你接受五分钟的采访，聊聊《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
And I was on with like, I don't know, like mad dog and jungle Pete or something like, you know?
当时采访我的好像是，我不知道，比如什么“疯狗”和“丛林皮特”之类的，你知道的吧？
And I was new to the whole publicity game, and it was only first season, and it's 6.30 in the morning, right?
而且我对整套宣传宣传游戏还很生疏，那才第一季，而且当时是早上六点半，对吧？
The coffee's barely hitting.
咖啡才刚起效。
And this guy says to me.
然后这家伙对我说。
Yeah, so Josh Radder, we were watching the show, and we both think that your show needs more cool characters, like Neil Patrick Harris, and less faggie ones like yours.
对啊，所以乔希·拉德纳，我们在看这部剧，我们俩都觉得你们的剧需要更多像尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯那样酷的角色，少一点像你这种娘娘腔的角色。
No way.
不会吧。
And I was really alive.
而且当时真的是直播吗？
Are you live?
你们在直播？
You're live on the air?
你在直播节目里？
And I was stunned into silence like I literally like I didn't know what I don't think you ever told me that story That's disgusting.
我当时震惊得说不出话来，真的就像……我不知道该怎么办，我觉得你从来没跟我讲过这个故事，这太令人恶心了。
Yeah.
对啊。
Yeah, I told my publicist who I'd only been with for five minutes, right?
对，我把这事告诉了我的宣传人员，我和她当时才合作了五分钟，对吧？
I was like, yeah, I'm never talking I should do not book me for shows like this or these guys ever again.
我说，行吧，我再也不接受采访了，以后不要再给我安排这种节目或者让这些家伙采访我了。
Yes, like I was really upset about it.
对，我当时真的为此气坏了。
Oh, yeah But then that's the kind of thing that made me insecure about like The part and the you know what I mean?
哦，对，但这就是那种会让我对这个角色以及……你知道我的意思吧？感到不自信的事情。
Yeah, yeah boy Those guys are not the target audience for the show.
对，对，天哪，那些家伙根本不是这部剧的目标受众。
That is not who we're writing that show for.
那根本不是我们为之写这部剧的人。
And also, if you don't understand that Barney was this huge parody of that kind of masculine behavior and not an endorsement of it, it never was.
而且，如果你不明白巴尼其实是对那种男子气概行为的巨大讽刺，而不是对它的赞同——它从来都不是。
Yes.
没错。
And some people really got that and some people really didn't get that and here we are.
有些人真的懂了，有些人真的没懂，然后就变成了现在这样。
But I can't believe I didn't even tell you that story for some reason.
但我真不敢相信，出于某种原因我连这个故事都没跟你讲过。
I've never heard you tell the story.
我从来没听你讲过这个故事。
That's insane.
这太疯狂了。
That's disgusting, that's a bummer.
这太恶心了，太扫兴了。
I'm sorry, you had to go straight to that.
我很抱歉，你一上来就遇到了这种事。
There is some weird stuff when you're out there promoting things.
你在外头宣传东西的时候，总会遇到一些奇奇怪怪的事情。
There's some weird stuff, right?
总有一些奇怪的事，对吧？
People will ask you, even the writers, the card man I had some experiences where people would ask questions that were so aggressive and strange and mean.
人们会问你问题，甚至那些编剧，卡片男，我曾经遇到过一些人，他们问的问题极具攻击性、奇怪而且刻薄。
And then you realize, not everyone is watching the same show.
然后你就会意识到，并不是每个人都在看同一部剧。
Like everyone's watching their own show.
就像每个人都在看他们自己的剧一样。
I did write down too much tongue guy unreasonably small-mouth opening girl worst superheroes ever.
我还记下了：舌吻太多的家伙、嘴巴小得离谱的女孩，史上最烂超级英雄。
Hello, by the way, I looked up this episode on Hemium Wiki, that is really funny.
顺便问一下，我刚才在Hemium Wiki上查了这一集，真的太搞笑了。
I looked up Hemium Wiki, they made the point that in drumroll, please, Victoria says to Ted, I don't know if we should kiss because then we won't have a great memory.
我查了Hemium Wiki，他们指出在《倒计时》那集里，维多利亚对泰德说，我不知道我们该不该接吻，因为那样我们就不会留下美好的记忆了。
What if you do this, or what if I do this, or what if you use too much tongue and it's a real motif and you're, there's a too much tongue to feel.
如果你这么做会怎么样，或者如果我这么做会怎么样，或者如果你舌吻太多会怎么样，这真是一个主题，而你……那里有一个“舌吻太多”的梗。
Yes.
是的。
No, there is a perfect amount.
不，数量刚刚好。
It's true.
真的。
It's my agenda.
这是我的目的。
I got it out there.
我把它表达出来了。
You know, I didn't have a memory.
你知道，我本来没有这段记忆。
I did have a memory about the tag.
我对那个收尾片段确实有点记忆。
The actress playing Alexa.
扮演亚历克萨的女演员。
I had to show her how to do the Ted, come on, like I had to demonstrate that because she wasn't there when we shot the other side.
我得教她怎么演泰德，拜托，就像我得示范一下一样，因为我们拍另一边的时候她不在场。
Yeah, it had to be a perfect mirror, right?
对，必须是个完美的镜像，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
And she was funny.
而且她很搞笑。
That really worked.
那段真的效果很好。
She was great.
她太棒了。
And like Ted.
就像泰德一样。
No.
不。
It's a perfect ending.
这是一个完美的结局。
It's a great, it's a great, it's a great episode, Glo.
这是一集太棒、太棒、太棒的节目，格洛。
Bravo.
太棒了。
Bravo, Loria.
太棒了，洛里亚。
It's a really good one.
这集真的很不错。
It's a group effort as we all know.
正如我们所知，这是团队合作的结果。
And we had great, we had great shining light beacon of light.
我们有很棒的、像耀眼灯塔一样闪耀的人。
Was it fun to rewatch it all these years later, Glo?
时隔多年再看，觉得有趣吗，格洛？
So fun.
超级有趣。
Oh, so fun.
哦，超级有趣。
Yeah.
对。
It's such a good time.
度过了非常美好的时光。
It was so, because we were all that age.
太棒了，因为我们当时都是那个年纪。
And it was, you know, really fun to remember.
而且，你知道，回忆起来真的很有趣。
Like we laughed all day and told stories.
就像我们整天都在大笑、讲故事。
and like you said, Josh, it made going through traumatic times much more bearable because of the therapy of getting to share it with the room, making people laugh, putting it out into the show, and then having people see it be seen.
就像你说的，乔希，经历痛苦的时期变得更加可以忍受了，因为在房间里分享这些是一种疗愈，逗大家笑，把它拍进节目里，然后让大家看到它、见证它。
I mean, it's, you know, when people come up and talk about various things I've done, I'm always, I'm so proud that this show broke my career.
我的意思是，你知道，当人们走过来谈论我做过的各种事情时，我总是、我为这部剧开启了我的职业生涯而感到无比骄傲。
I mean, it made me, it really, it really changed the course of my career.
我是说，它成就了我，它真的、真的改变了我职业生涯的轨迹。
And I'm so grateful that I got to be there for whatever 64 episodes or whatever.
我非常感激能够参与其中，无论那是64集还是多少集。
It strikes me when you say we were that age, making the show about people that age.
当你说我们是那个年纪、拍摄关于那个年纪的人的剧集时，这让我很有感触。
And I think like, if you look at a show like another memory show, like the Wonder Years, that was clearly people older looking back on the time.
我想，如果你看另一部怀旧剧，比如《纯真年代》，那显然是年长的人在回首过去。
This show is about someone older looking back on a time.
这部剧讲的是一个年长的人在回首过去。
But none of us were writing it.
但我们当时都不是编剧。
were in the time they were living in the past and they were imagining the future rather than the reverse.
我们当时正处于那个时代，生活在过去，我们在想象未来，而不是相反。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
And it changes it.
这改变了性质。
It changes the feeling.
它改变了那种感觉。
But by the way, I don't remember.
不过话说回来，我不记得了。
I'm so impressed by Ted's memory.
我对泰德的记忆力印象深刻。
I know, even though I'm a little loud boy.
我知道，尽管我只是个有点吵闹的男孩。
He remembers so much more than we do now at this age.
以我们现在的年纪来看，他记得的事情比我们多得多。
What we keep asking the question is, what we're seeing Ted's version of it or are we seeing the real story and Ted is telling?
我们一直想问的问题是，我们看到的是泰德的版本，还是真实的故事，而泰德在讲述？
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
Oh yeah, I think it's Ted's version now.
哦，是的，我觉得现在这绝对是泰德的版本。
I feel like I just ate a sandwich from this question.
我觉得我听了这个问题就像吃了一个三明治一样。
I feel so high right now.
我感觉现在嗨得不行。
What if we're all just existing with an intense room?
如果我们都只是在一个浓烈的空间里存在呢？
It's just we're gonna keep unpacking this.
这只是说明我们会继续剖析这个话题。
So romantic.
太浪漫了。
It's still romantic.
依然很浪漫。
The story is so romantic and it's seen through this lovely lens of let's also say a good man.
这个故事太浪漫了，它通过这样一个美好的视角呈现出来，而且还得说，这是一个好男人。
I think that like we struggle right now to find good men on TV and this is a show about somebody who's legitimately looking And for his life partner, it's so pure and really sweet and like, he's a good guy doing his best and making mistakes along the way.
我觉得我们现在很难在电视上找到好男人，而这部剧讲的就是一个真诚地在寻找人生伴侣的人，他是那么纯粹、那么可爱，他是一个尽力做好事、一路上也会犯错的好家伙。
And that's something we don't get to see very much anymore in a comical way.
这是我们现在以喜剧方式很难再看到的东西了。
And I think it's not a surprise that people are still so drawn to the show so many years later.
我想，多年后人们依然如此被这部剧吸引，这并不令人意外。
That's what makes a show classic is really decent people doing their best and we get to laugh along.
成就一部经典剧集的，正是真正正派的人在尽力做到最好，而我们则能一起开怀大笑。
Welcome back to the show.
欢迎回到节目中。
We're wrapping things up for today.
我们今天节目快要接近尾声了。
We've had such a good time talking to our friend Gloria Calderon-Kellett.
和我们的朋友格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆-凯利聊天非常开心。
Gloria, what a treat to see you and hear from you and just spend this time together.
格洛丽亚，能见到你、听到你的声音并一起度过这段时光，真是一件乐事。
Thank you so much for being here.
非常感谢你能来到这里。
Likewise.
彼此彼此。
Yeah.
对。
As we like to do in what we call the C-block.
正如我们喜欢在所谓的C板块做的那样。
I don't know why we do that, we just do it.
我不知道为什么要这么做，我们就是这么做了。
Thank you for coming in.
谢谢你来作客。
ASMR.
ASMR。
We like, that's right.
我们喜欢，没错。
That's right.
没错。
If people use this to fall asleep, I hope that that knocks them out.
如果人们用这个来助眠，我希望这能把他们催眠过去。
But we like to read at the beginning of the show.
但我们喜欢在节目开始时阅读。
We obviously like to play a voice note from fans.
我们显然喜欢播放粉丝的语音留言。
And at the end of the show, we like to read a note that we've received.
在节目结束时，我们喜欢读一读收到的来信。
If you would like to write us or record a voice note, please go to how we made your mother.com H-W-M-Y-M.
如果你想给我们写信或录制语音留言，请访问 howwemetyourmother.com，拼写是 H-W-M-Y-M。
Go to contact, follow the directions.
点击“联系我们”，按照说明操作。
Very easy.
非常简单。
This is our favorite thing to hear from you guys.
这是我们最喜欢听你们分享的内容。
What the show means to you, you know, anecdotes about your life, how the show has affected you, how it changed things for you.
这部剧对你们意味着什么，你知道的，关于你们生活的趣事，这部剧是如何影响你们的，它是如何改变你们的。
Let us know.
让我们知道吧。
That's part of this whole thing, it's here.
这也是整个节目的一部分，它就在这里。
So, Glow is going to be our guest reader.
所以，格洛将成为我们的特邀朗读嘉宾。
guest reader for this week.
本周的特邀朗读嘉宾。
So take it away, Gloria.
那么开始吧，格洛丽亚。
Very exciting.
太令人兴奋了。
Okay.
好的。
This comes from Jane from Honolulu, Aloha.
这封信来自檀香山的简，阿洛哈。
I just came across your podcast the last couple of weeks and have already finished the first season.
我过去几周刚偶然发现你们的播客，并且已经听完了第一季。
It's making me feel very nostalgic.
这让我感到非常怀旧。
Although I must have watched your show when it first came out, my fond memories are of watching it a few years later with my two young sons, starting when they were probably four and six years old.
虽然我当年首播时肯定看过这部剧，但我美好的回忆是几年后和两个年幼的儿子一起看，当时他们大概四六岁。
As a full-time working mom with a 40 to 60 minute commute to the kid's school and my office, the end of the day was exhausting.
作为一名全职工作的妈妈，上下班去孩子学校和我的办公室需要40到60分钟，一天结束时已经筋疲力尽了。
After some time an hour in traffic, it was shuffling kids and all their things into the house, making dinner while helping with homework, washing dishes, and cleaning up.
在交通里堵了一个小时后，就是把孩子们和他们所有的东西弄进屋里，一边辅导家庭作业一边做晚饭，洗碗，然后打扫卫生。
Then the three of us would plop down on the couch and watch how I met your mother.
然后我们三个就会瘫倒在沙发上，观看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
They were too young to understand all the jokes.
他们太小了，听不懂所有的笑话。
Yes, but they loved the show anyway.
是的，但他们不管怎样还是很喜欢这部剧。
and I love how time slowed down while we watched.
我喜欢我们在观看时慢下来的时光。
With my youngest sitting snuggly in my lap and my oldest cuddled up next to me, it was my half hour of adult time that the kids took part in.
小儿子舒服地坐在我怀里，大儿子依偎在我身旁，这是属于我的半小时成人时间，孩子们也参与其中。
After the show was over, the TV would go off and it was back to racing around for bath time, teeth brushing, books before bed and settling down.
节目结束后，电视就会关掉，接着又是忙乱的洗澡、刷牙、睡前读书和准备睡觉。
Watching the show, there were probably a few times where I had to cover their eyes, but for the most part, it gave me the chance to explain things like, Bernie is showing how not to be.
看节目时，大概有几次我不得不捂住他们的眼睛，但大部分时候，这给了我一个解释事情的机会，比如，巴尼是在展示如何做反面教材。
I was pleased when my friend said, he wanted to be just like Marshall and Lily when he.
当我的朋友说他想变得和马歇尔以及莉莉一样时，我很高兴。
As they got older, we continued to watch on the couch, sometimes binge watching during a rainstorm or a sick day.
随着他们长大，我们继续在沙发上一起看剧，有时在暴风雨天或生病请假的日子里还会疯狂刷剧。
Soon they were teenagers who came and went, so I would sit on the couch and watch an episode or two by myself.
很快他们成了来去匆匆的青少年，于是我就会自己坐在沙发上看上一两集。
In passing, they'd often ask, which one I was watching and all I'd have to say was a word or phrase like snowstorm or boats, boats, boats, and they'd know, I mean, sometimes if we were bored, I'd say, give me two numbers, and they'd randomly pick two numbers.
顺便一提，他们经常会问我在看哪一集，而我只需要说一个词或短语，比如暴风雨或船、船、船，他们就心领神会了；我的意思是，有时如果我们觉得无聊，我会说，给我两个数字，他们就会随机挑两个数字。
First one for season, the second one for episode, and we'd watch that episode together now.
第一个数字代表季数，第二个数字代表集数，然后我们现在就会一起看那一集。
You would be a good one.
你一定是个不错的选择。
Now my oldest is away on the mainland at college, and I'm starting to feel the dread of an empty nest.
现在我的大儿子远在大陆上大学，我开始感到空巢带来的焦虑。
My youngest is not so young anymore, but will sit and watch with me as a happy palate cleanser after watching something scary or dark before bed.
我的小儿子已经不再那么小了，但在睡前看了恐怖或黑暗的节目后，他会坐下来和我一起看，权当是一个开心的精神调剂。
My oldest recently texted me a photo of himself in a suit for a kid who grew up in Hawaii.
我大儿子最近发短信给我一张他穿西装的照片，对于一个在夏威夷长大的孩子来说。
It's not something you see before making a presentation.
这不是你在做演讲前能常见到的。
And I had this sincerest pleasure of texting back, you suit it up.
于是我怀着最真诚的高兴回复道：“你穿上西装真帅（suit up）。”
I will forever equate how I met your mother with the feeling of sitting with my boys, laughing together, sometimes crying together and being present with each other to enjoy 20 minutes of stillness.
我永远会把《老爸老妈的浪漫史》与这样一种感觉画上等号：和我的男孩们坐在一起，一起欢笑，有时一起落泪，彼此陪伴，享受20分钟的宁静。
I was lucky to have many of these moments throughout their childhood where I could marvel the observations of a five-year-old and then nine-year-old, then a teenager with some shows sparking conversation and some inspiring contemplation.
我很幸运在他们的童年里拥有许多这样的时刻，我可以惊叹于一个五岁、九岁再到一个青少年的观察力，有些剧集能引发对话，有些则能激发深思。
I'm hopeful that when both my kids are fully grown adults and I'm an wrinkly old woman, I'll be able to call or text them wherever they are and say, zitch dog or thank you Linus or suit up.
我希望当我的两个孩子都完全长大成人，而我变成一个满脸皱纹的老太太时，无论他们身在何处，我都能够打电话或发短信给他们，说一句“zitch dog（快看狗）”或者“谢谢你，莱纳斯”或者“穿上西装（suit up）”。
And they'll know exactly what I mean.
他们就会完全明白我的意思。
Oh my gosh, wow.
哦天哪，哇。
That's really moving.
真是太感人了。
I find that very moving because that letter covers like the huge span of time in and of itself.
我觉得非常感人，因为那封信本身就涵盖了如此漫长的时间跨度。
She took us on a journey.
她带我们经历了一场旅程。
That was really well done.
这真的写得很好。
That was a great letter.
这是一封很棒的信。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I feel the weight of the journey there.
我能感受到那段旅程的分量。
I love him Yem Roolette.
我喜欢 Yem Roolette。
Like just call it out.
就像直接喊出来一样。
Just call it out and just let in the face to side.
直接喊出来，然后……
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
I love that.
我喜欢这样。
I also just, you know, kind of what we're doing, like growing older with a piece of art, you know, kind of alongside you.
我只是，你知道的，就像我们正在做的那样，随着一件艺术品一起变老，你知道的，它就陪伴在你身边。
And as an access point to bond with your kids, My son watches the show with us occasionally, also far too young, six people, I don't think he should be watching it.
作为与孩子们建立羁绊的切入点，我儿子偶尔也会和我们一起看这个节目，虽然他还太小，才六岁，我觉得他不该看的。
But he does, when I talk, he kind of his attention drifts.
但他确实看了，当我说话时，他的注意力有点分散。
He knows that voice.
他认得那个声音。
That's very cool.
这太酷了。
Yeah, that's very cool.
对，这太酷了。
Which is funny because I remember the reason they wouldn't let me do the narrators because they thought my voice didn't sound old enough.
这很有趣，因为我记得他们不让我担任旁白的原因，是他们觉得我的声音听起来不够老。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
But I think my voice sounds somewhat similar to how it sounded.
但我觉得我的声音听起来和以前差不多。
Your voice sounds exactly the same.
你的声音听起来完全一样。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, well, that was a lovely letter.
好吧，那是一封很棒的信。
Thank you so much and thank you to Gloria for being here.
非常感谢，也谢谢格洛丽亚来到这里。
Thank you, Glo.
谢谢你，格洛（Glo）。
Just wonderful to see you and what a great episode, how we met everyone else.
见到你真是太棒了，这是一集多么棒的节目啊，“我们是如何遇见其他所有人的”。
And we'll see you next time.
我们下期再见。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《How We Made Your Mother》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
and it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 呈现和发行。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey, and the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
本节目还由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）担任执行制片人，由我——亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作和剪辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matika.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matika）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, Appointed Blue Studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Katherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是来自 Appointed Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的 Z 世代大师、数字内容制作人是艾米莉·布隆伯格（Emily Blumberg），助理制作人是凯瑟琳·格罗夫（Katherine Grove）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
这确实有助于扩大宣传。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《纽约市》，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供了额外音乐。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萨姆·西博尔德（Sam Theobold）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Our stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
在各大书店购买克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说《That's Not How It Happened》，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他的其他发表作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substack.
您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的《Dead Father Society》。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何为本节目持续为先天性心脏病研究筹款的公益活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”标签页。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上会跳舞。